pour que nous puissions donc débuter
notre audition parce que euh je pense
que bien évidemment les questions seront
encore une fois très nombreuses et que
vous savez que à 11h nous avons une
autre audition qui succède à l'audition
de Monsieur Sébastien Winsor qui est
donc présidente de chambre d'agriculture
France donc nous vous remercions bien
évidemment pour votre venue devant notre
commission au milieu d'une actualité
agricole pour le moins extrêmement
chargée vous présidez depuis 2020
Chambre d'Agriculture France que l'on
connaissait auparavant sous le nom
d'apkaa l'assemblée permanente des
chambres d'agriculture avant cela bien
qu'issu du milieu agricole vous ne vous
êtes installé en policulture élevage
qu'après une formation d'ingénieur et un
début de carrière hors agriculture vous
avez ensuite exercé plusieurs fonctions
de représentation syndicale au sein de
la Fédération des oléo protéagineux et
institutionnel en présidant la Chambre
d'Agriculture régionale de Normandie
avant de devenir plus récemment premier
vice-président du Conseil économique
social et environnemental vous présidez
un établissement public à caractère
administratif qui compte 8200
collaborateurs et assume à la fois des
mission de services publics comme
l'identification des animaux ou
l'animation du programme de
développement agricole et rural la
représentation du monde agricole au
travers des élections consulair les
prochaines élections auront lieu en
2025 les Chambres d'agriculture sont
autant de petits parlements du monde
agricole et forestier et plus largement
de la ruralité ce n'est pas pour rien
que plusieurs de nos collègues ont
d'ailleurs exercé des responsabilités
notamment électives aux chambres
d'agriculture de ce fait elles étaient
aux premières loges de la crise que nous
venons de traverser elles avaient même
par bien des aspects vu venir et alerter
sur ce mécontentement sourd qui a fini
par éclater nous ne pourrons bien
évidemment qu'effleurer la vaste
question des déterminants de cette crise
et je rappelle qu'un panorama assez
complet des difficultés de la ferme
France avait déjà été dressé dans les
deux rapports de notre collègue Laurent
du plomb sur la compétitivité et sur la
souveraineté de plus sans aller jusqu'à
dire que les événements récents ont fini
de déployer tous leurs effets force et
d'admettre qu'une première phase du
mouvement est bel et bien derrière nous
une autre s'ouvre avec d'abord dans 3
semaines le salon de l'agriculture qui
sera l'occasion de prendre la
température et avec ensuite un texte
législatif pour lequel vous avez piloté
au prier semestre 2023 les concertations
régionales organisées en trois groupes
de travail orientation formation
installation transmission et changement
climatique après plusieurs REP reports
son calendrier pourrait bien être
repoussé cette fois-ci que de quelques
semaines en tout cas on attend cela pour
savoir quand le Sénat sera saisi de ce
texte de loi alors si vous le voulez
bien c'est plutôt sur ce projet de loi
d'orientation pour le renouvellement des
générations en agriculture nouveau nom
du projet de loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricole que nous voudrions
vous entendre premièrement nous
voudrions avoir votre éclairage sur
l'accueil réservé par le monde agricole
à ces deux paquets d'annonces du Premier
ministre et de ses ministres qui
pourrait être injecté dans un volet
simplification et ou compétitivité du
texte à venir deuxièmement que faut-il
penser de ce nouveau guichet unique
France service agriculture qui serait
l'une des mesures structurantes de ce
texte cela semble correspondre à une
attente forte de la profession mais il
semble y avoir débat sur la question de
savoir s'il faut en faire un passage
obligé lors de l'installation par
ailleurs quelle articulation avec les
chambres départementales et quelle
différence fondamentalement entre ce
nouvel acteur et les points accueil
transmission installation transmission
qui existait déjà auparavant
compétitivité restaurée pour la ferme
France et fluidité administrative
renforcée pour l'installation de jeunes
agriculteurs me semble être les deux
piliers d'une politique sérieuse de
renouvellement des générations voilà
sans plus tarder je vous laisse la
parole je précise que cette audition est
captée et diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et que la vidéo sera
ensuite disponible en vidéo à la demande
monsieur le Président je vous laisse la
parole et ensuite bien sûr on ouvrira
les débats avec l'ensemble de nos
collègues merci madame la Présidente
bonjour à toutes et à
tous
peut-être avant de revenir sur les
annonces du Premier ministre peut-être
revenir aussi sur les causes de ce
mouvement du monde agricole
voilà deux points d'abord regardons où
le mouvement le mouvement est parti en
Occitanie et l'occcitanie est
probablement dans une
situation un peu différente du reste de
de la France ù qui est au moins la
situation d'un certain nombre de zones
du Sud mais qui est pas d'un point de
vue économique la situation de toute la
France pourquoi probablement parce que
c'est une des zones où quand on fait
l'analyse des revenus o les revenus
agricoles étaient les plus bas plusieurs
explications à ça c'est d'abord une des
zones les plus touchées par le
réchauffement climatique
quand vous regardez les Pyrénées
Orientales où il est tombé 200 mm en un
an c'est-à-dire moins que ce qu'il tombe
au Qatar en une année où il y a pas eu
de pluie significative de plus de 10 mm
depuis quasiment 2 ans euh je pense que
j'ai pas besoin de d'aller beaucoup plus
loin dans le dans le dessin pour
expliquer que l'agriculture dans ces
zones-là ne peut pas économiquement être
dans une situation fleurissante deuxième
point c'est que on était donc des des
potentiels plus faibles plus touché
par la partie alors plus touché par la
partie économique et puis avec des
productions qui sont aussi les
productions qui étaient les plus en
difficulté notamment une production de
fruits et légumes relativement forte et
c'est celle qui était les une de celles
où on avait pas eu où on a eu le moins
de revalorisation et d'inflation sur les
les les produits et donc de
revalorisation pour le monde agricole dû
à une concurrence assz asse forte sur
ces sujets- là de produits d'importation
avec des écarts de de de règles un peu
plus importants que sur d'autres
cultures c'est pas le cas des céréales
par exemple en céréal on a toute une
partie de la France qui a eu des
rendements très faibles toutes les zones
ce qu'on appelle les zones
intermédiaires des charantes au Grand
Est mais pour le coup dans ces zones-là
la revalorisation du prix des céréales
était venue compenser quelque part une
baisse des niveaux de rendement ça n'a
pas été le cas sur les productions de
fruits et légumes euh donc voilà une
zone qui était peut-être un peu plus
touchée que les autres économiquement ce
qui peut expliquer les choses je veux
aussi le dire je pense que dans les
autres zones de France ce qui a amener
le la crise agricole qu'on a vécu c'est
pas un sujet de revenu ou c'est
peut-être un sujet de revenu en devenir
mais c'est pas un sujet de trésorerie
euh c'est peut-être un sujet en devenir
parce que quand même la baisse des cours
avec les prix des intrants qui ne
subissent pas la même baisse amène le
fameux effet ciseau qu'on qu'on connaît
tous maintenant et qui mettait les
agriculteurs dans des perspectives un
peu moins favorables mais en tout cas
sur toute la moitié les 2/ers nord de la
France on nait pas de problème de
trésorerie au moment où la crise est
arrivée c'était probablement enin c'est
pas c'était c'est probablement beaucoup
plus un mouvement de
de de grogne de ralbol sur une
agriculture
suradministrée et sur lesqueles les
agriculteurs ne comprennent pas parfois
des injonctions contradictoires qui
peuvent leur être donné aussi par un
traitement silo des sujets je vais juste
prendre un
exemple sur la culture du colsin on a
d'un côté une réflexion sur la directive
nitrate qui veut amener les agriculteurs
à ne plus utiliser d'engrais à l'automne
pour éviter les risques de fuite malgré
d'ailleurs un certain nombre d'études
qui monquent que si les les doses
faibles sont amenées il y a pas de
risque de fuite mais globalement la
vision nitrate
amenait les réflexions nationales à dire
vous en avez pas besoin donc on les
interdit sauf que la réalité c'est que
ces nitrates là amené à l'automne en
petite dose et donc sans risque de fuite
c'était la seule façon de faire grossir
le cols plus vite qu'il n'était mangé
par les insectes et donc d'éviter un
traitement insecticide et donc on avait
une injonction aux agriculteurs d'un
côté de leur dire développer des
méthodes alternatives aux insecticides
et quand ils arrivent avec les méthodes
alternatives aux insecticides de leur
dire vous avez pas le droit de les
utiliser parce qu'il y a une
réglementation nitrate qui vous le
permet pas juste ça dans la tête des
agriculteurs c'est extrêmement délétaire
et ça amène des situations
d'incompréhension totale où on leur
demande des choses et où on leur fait
vivre l'inverse le deuxième sujet qui a
été probablement aussi très perturbateur
pour les agriculteur c'est une politique
globalement portée un peu par tout le
monde de monter en gamme et une
situation économique où les Français
face à une inflation et une inflation
avec des dépenses contraintes dans leur
budget augmentation des dépenses de
déplacement augmentation des dépenses de
allez qui qui sont prélevé tous les
débuts de mois je je vois des téléphones
s'agités mais le budget téléphone et
cetera tous ces budgets là étant à la
hausse est prélevé la seule alternative
qui restait au français c'était de faire
l'arbitrage sur le budget alimentaire et
le budget alimentaire des Français dans
une période où on demander aux
agriculteurs de monter en gamme a baissé
de 15 % ce qui est inédit le budget
alimentaire en proportion baissait en
valeur absolue ne baissait pas et donc
le budget s'est effondré de 15 % en un
an quand on baisse le budget de 15 % les
Français ne mangent pas 15 % de moins
donc ils sont descendus en gamme et donc
dans une période où on a fait monter les
agriculteurs en gamme générant des des
coûts plus élevés on a vu une baisse du
budget des consommateurs et là aussi un
message extrêmement compliqué pour les
agriculteurs où on leur dit faites des
efforts environnementaux mais où on leur
dit il faut produire moins cher et c'est
probablement aussi un des éléments qui a
amené ce mouvement de grogne
relativement fort voilà donc j'irai
peut-être pas beaucoup plus loin sur les
éléments de compréhension je répondrai à
vos questions si vous le voulez après
sur les annonces qu'a fait le premier
ministre sur l'emble je vais peut-être
pas revenir sur tous les points je vais
au moins me centrer sur ceux qui sont
liés directement au métier des des champ
d'agriculture je vais peut-être
commencer par un de ceux qui est le plus
emblématique enfin les sujets des phyo
par exemple fait font partie des sujets
assez emblématique et des sujets sur
lesquels il y avait une incompréhension
forte du monde agricole je commencerai
par le sujet du conseil stratégique
phito effectivement dans l'absolu je
suis assez d'accord que pour un
agriculteur une fois tous les 5 ans se
poser la question de l'utilisation de
ces phyos et comment il peut faire pour
réduire l'utilisation de ces phyos c'est
plutôt une bonne idée et je pense que le
monde agricole est prêt à l'accepter le
seul sujet c'est la façon dont ça a été
porté avec un certifito que qui existait
déjà qui doit avoir lieu tous les 5 ans
sur lequel on avait déjà une formation
des agriculteurs et puis on est venu
rajouter à ce certifito un conseil
stratégique phito qui est à la fois
décorrélé mais lié puisque pour avoir
son certifito il fallait dans les 5
années qui précèdent
le le certifito avoir fait deux
stratégique phyo séparé d'au moins 2 ans
déjà quand vous avez expliqué ça et puis
ça dépend en plus de la date du
renouvellement du certifito parce que
tout ça lié à la date du renouvellement
du
certifito un peu compliqué quand même à
comprendre pour l'agriculteur parfois
aussi un peu compliqué d'expliquer à des
agriculteurs très leaders par exemple
qui étaient déjà dans des groupes de
développement qui étai amené à avoir une
dizaine de réunions par an en collectif
sur leur pratique phyo quex aussi il
allent faire falloir qu'ils ait ce ce
certificat et qu' avait pas
d'équivalence tout ça a amené une
incompréhension assez forte et moi le
premier j'avais un peu de mal à savoir
quand je devais faire ce fameux conseil
stratégique phyo et je me posais encore
la question du pourquoi je devais le
faire puisque je suis dans un groupe de
développement dans un groupe défill où
j'ai quand même une réflexion
approfondie et encore voilà donc et et
et pas d'équivalence pour reconnaître
tout ça alors que ces mêmes groupes d'
fil sont financés par l'État à côté je
le dit quand même est reconnu euh et
donc ça a amené de l'incompréhension et
une situation où on dit il faut
rassembler tout ça il faut arrêter
d'avoir un conseil stratégique phito
d'un côté un certifito de l'autre il
faut remettre tout ça dans une seule et
même enveloppe et en limitant
l'inflation temps et coût de manière à
ce que ça reste accessible et
compréhensible par l'agriculteur voilà
donc c'est pas un refus du sujet phito
c'est pas un refus d'obstacle sur le
sujet phito c'est un refus d'une comp
excité dans la façon de le gérer qui est
totalement incompréhensible ceci
d'autant plus incompréhensible que nous
chambre d'agriculture qui faisions cet
accompagnement l'État n'a jamais accepté
de nous donner les dates de
renouvellement des certifitau pour qu'on
communique auprès des agriculteurs pour
leur dire à quel moment il devait avoir
ce conseil donc à partir de là on était
dans
un voilà et en plus personne n
communiqué sur le sujet donc tout ça on
avait tout ce qu'il faut pour faire
exploser le sujet donc voilà je le dis
parce qu'en ce moment on voit les choses
s'inverser en disant les agriculteurs
refusent l'obstacle du sujet phyo non
c'est pas ça si on refuse et on ne
traitera pas le sujet phyo par des
injonctions et par une multiplication
des formations une formation bien faite
à un moment donné si elle est faite
comme il fa avec l'agriculteur elle est
suffisante et il va pas réviser sa
stratégie phyo tous les 6 mois il faut
qu'il ait une stratégie à moyen terme
deuxème sujet qui a généré beaucoup
d'incompréhension le sujet des zones de
non traitement
euh sur le sujet des des des zones de
nontaitement
euh l'histoire commence en 2022
où il y a une règle il y a des règles
européennes il y a dans chaque produit
phytosanitaire quand il est homologué un
certain nombre de tests qui sont faits
sur la toxicité et sur les risques
d'intoxication quand on est à 5 m à 20 m
à 100 m donc il y a il y a quand même
des choses qui sont faites à partir de
ça l'an donne une autorisation de sur le
marché qui d'ailleurs dans certains cas
imposent des distances d'éloignement par
rapport au voisinage et ça c'est basé
sur des faits scientifiques et moi je
peux pas entendre que l'an c'est pas un
organisme neutre on est de temps en
temps suffisamment àalé contre l'an pour
ne pas entendre que ils sont laxistes
dans la façon de de d'homologuer les
produits euh donc
l'aness prend ses positions mais on
estime que c'est pas suffisant et on
rajoute une distance par rapport au
voisinage de 5 m
euh pour les grandes cultures mais de 20
m pour la vigne ou l'arboriculture ce
qui est quand même compliqué he quand
vous regardez le myage du monde viticole
dans le monde urbain dans un certain
nombre d'endroits 20 m c'est c'est
supprimé quasiment un certain nombre de
parcelles de
vigne l'incompréhension elle vient dans
le monde agricole de pourquoi on fait
homologuer un produit si si derrière on
redéfinit une zone et puis le jour où on
fait ce texte définissant des zones on
dit on va faire des charpes pour réduire
les zones expliquez-moi la logique quand
même de déterminer une et en même temps
de dire on va faire une charte pour
réduire la
zone réduction des
zones avec OK quand on est bordure d'un
jardin on peut comprendre le débat quand
on est sur la bordure d'un parc qui fait
10 hectares le débat est déjà un peu
plus compliqué de savoir pourquoi on
s'en éloigne et la difficulté pour le
monde agricole c'est aussi la double
peine une urbanisation qui grignote des
terres agricoles et quand ça urbanise à
côté de chez l'agriculteur on fait lui
reculer alors que on devrait dans la
conception du lotissement intégrer cette
zone de protection avec la difficulté
c'est qu'il faut l'entretenir et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que les lotisseurs
n'en veulent pas parce que il faudrait
l'entretenir mais l'entretenir sans
accès aux enfants parce que par exemple
si si on en fait une zone de jeu des
enfants voilà euh donc ces
ZNT incomprises et puis le dernier point
c'est une obligation de prévenance des
voisins où on dit on va mettre le
girophare et où euh ben les
derniers voilà aujourd'hui on a un
tribunal pilote qui a porté ce sujet des
chartes puisqu'elles ont quasiment tout
été attaqués on a perdu voilà et le
Tribunal reconnaît que la prévenance du
girophare n'est pas suffisante sans
expliquer comment on va faire et moi je
suis preneur j'ai j'ai un peu plus de
400 voisins sur mes mon exploitation
agricole je vois pas comment je peux les
prévenir tous d'abord j'ai pas leur
numéro de téléphone et puis si je les
appelle tous les matins avant d'aller
traiter ils vont assz vite en avoir
marre voilà sur ce point-là
OFB
OFB le le sujet est et parfois de
l'incompréhension
sur de l'ofb c'est c'est parfois de
l'incompréhension sur comment
euh un certain nombre de condamnations
qui ont pu avoir lieu je vais englober
avec le sujet et euh on a côté Chambre
d'Agriculture fortement poussé à planter
des ha on a des agriculteurs qu'on a
accompagné dans la plantation de ha
premier point euh on nous dit que pour
toucher le bonus e qui est lié à la PAC
de 7 € de l'hctare euh il y a une règle
qui est apparue dans la PAC qu'il faut
faire certifier la haie par un organisme
certificateur coût de la certification
1000 € pour toucher à 7 € mais en
réalité 50 agriculteurs sont aller
chercher la certification et deuxème
point des agriculteurs qu'on a
accompagné qui ont à un moment voulu
déplacer des a parce que on a besoin de
faire une entrée de l'exploitation
agricole on a besoin de faire un
bâtiment une exploitation sa vie qui
sont d'accord pour replanter la demande
l'accord de la DDT puisque dans le cadre
de la PAC il faut demander un accord je
le dis quand même pour écrire le dossier
pour demander l'accord on est obligé de
déplacer un technicien et on fait un
rapport d'une cinquantaine de pages
parfois pour 20 m de ha parce qu'il y a
pas de règle définies sur quels sont les
coefficients de remplacement et cetera
on a l'accord de la DDT l'ofb vient
contrôle et dresse un procès verbal pour
destruction d'habitat potentiel on
envoie le même technicien regarder pour
comprendre et le technicien dit mais il
y avait pas de nid dans l' et lafb nous
répond non c'est habitat potentiel c'est
pas habitat voilà et donc on a quand
même dans la Manche par exemple 12
agriculteurs qui sont au tribunal sur ce
sujet-là je peux vous dire que nous pour
inciter les agriculteurs à continuer à
planter des ha on sort les rames voire
on les sort même plus parce que on se
fait renvoyer chez nous voilà un peu sur
les les les les points majeurs des
annonces je reviendrai enfin voilà je
pourrais répondre à des questions sur
sur les zones humides je pense qu'on a
aussi un sujet sur la mobilisation de
l'inrae mais j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure si si vous avez des questions
euh peut-être peut-être aborder deux ou
trois points je pense que dans
l'ensemble de de cette politique aussi
un des points majeurs c'est qu'on a
beaucoup basé le progrès des agriculteur
sur la contrainte et la normalisation de
ce qu'il doivent faire je reste persuadé
que dans une phase où on doit
accompagner les agriculteurs où où il y
a quand même un certain forme de petite
révolution qui se prépare entre le
changement climatique qui impacte les
agriculteurs le besoin de produire plus
de biomasse pour répondre aux enjeux de
décarbonation et cetera on a un enjeu
d'accompagnement des agriculteurs au
changement qui est colossal on est
probablement dans un besoin
d'accompagner sur des changements de
pratique les agriculteurs
euh un peu comme on a pu être amené à le
faire dans les années 70 avec voilà mais
mais les agriculteurs on les ACC si on
veut qu'il change il faut les
accompagner dans le changement pas les
pas leur donner des injonctions de
changement et cette politique
d'accompagnement au changement c'est
probablement un des oubliés de la
politique agricole actuelle où il y a
beaucoup d'aide à l'investissement où il
y a beaucoup de traitements en en
en silo où il y a une politique sur les
phyos une politique sur la haie une
politique sur les nitrates une politique
sur la biodiversité une politique sur la
prédation moi je suis pas en tant que
chambre je suis pas capable d'aller voir
un agriculteur et de l'accompagner dans
ses changements de pratique une fois sur
les phyos une fois sur la haie une fois
voilà il faut bien qu'on aborde le sujet
un peu globalement on a besoin d'un
accompagnement ou changement qui est
colossal chez les agriculteurs pour
qu'ils comprennent pour que c'est soit
leur propre projet qu'ils écrivent et
qu'on les accompagne dans ce projet et
pas des injonctions qui leur tombent
dessus et ça c'est un peu l'oublier des
politiques actuelles je dirais et puis
dernier point puisque vous m'avez
interrogé sur la loi d'orientation et de
renouvellement des générations
euh je
je je pense que je je vous fais pas de
dessin en vous expliquant que ce
renouvellement des génération il il
prend une ampleur dans les 10 ans qui
viennent
énorme à force de dire la moitié des
agricultur
auront atteint l'âge de la retraite dans
10 ans c'est plutôt 55 %
aujourd'hui ces renouvellement se
faisaient essentiellement il y a 10 ans
par des enfants d'agriculteur qui
s'installaient aujourd'hui c'est plus de
la moitié des gens qui s'installent qui
sont pas issus du milieu agricole et
c'est plutôt une bonne chose je pense
que ça amène un regard différent cette
mixité et cetera mais les besoins
d'accompagnement sont très différents
les besoins d'accompagnement quand vous
aviez un agriculteur il un fils
d'agriculteur il fallait plutôt à faire
différemment de ce que faisait son père
dans la viticulture j'ai en discuté avec
des gens dans le beaujolet par exemple
il disait que un des enjeux c'était
d'accompagner les fils d'agriculteurs
sur les enjeux de prendre en main leur
commercialisation à l'inverse des non
agriculteurs quand ils arrivent ils ont
souvent réfléchi à leur
commercialisation il faut les accompagn
sur les enjeux techniques de production
voilà donc on a besoin d'accompagner des
projets avec des maturités de projets
qui
sont moins avancé parce que souvent des
projets plus différents de ce que
faisait le prédécesseur et donc on a
besoin de renforcer l'accompagnement du
jeune dans la maturité de son projet et
de l'aider à aller jusqu'au bout parce
que les montants d'investissement aussi
ont augmenté hein aujourd'hui des des
montants de
reprise en dessous de de quelques
centaines de millions d'euros il y en a
plus y compris sur du maréchage les
niveaux d'investissement sont
relativement forts et donc il faut
accompagner correctement le projet pour
qu'il soit viable il faut accompagner
des projets beaucoup plus diverses et
beaucoup plus variés que ce qu'on a eu
par le passé de moins en moins avec des
modèles et le tout c'est d'aider
l'agriculteur à bâtir son propre modèle
et que le modèle soit cohérent et de
l'aider à avoir un regard sur l'ensemble
des sujets économiques mais aussi les
sujets phyau parceque ce sont des sujets
de société et et les attentes du
consommateur et cetera et puis le
dernier point qui complique l'équation
c'est le besoin de les accompagner face
au changement climatique et ça c'est
prévu dans la loi d'orientation il est
nécessaire que un jeune au moment où il
s'installe et quand même un peu imaginer
quel sera l'impact du changement
climatique sur son exploitation dans les
10 ans qui viennent de manière à s'y
préparer un peu dans les les choix
d'investissement qu'il va faire mais il
faut aussi être vigilant à pas trop
complexifier le parcours à
l'installation on a des réflexions sur
euh un diagnostic santé des sols par
exemple moi qui a un diagnostic sur la
fertilité des sols que le jeune
connaisse l'état de ses parcelles c'est
très bien attention aussi à ne pas faire
un truc où on va demander aux jeunes 5
ou 6 études avant de s'installer un coup
déjà de 60000 € d'études avant qu'il
commen à mettre le moindre euros dans la
reprise de l'exploitation enfin au débat
est-ce que il faut que ce soit
obligatoire ou pas moi on peut faire
tout le parcours qu'on veut pour
accompagner le jeune si un moment il y a
pas une incitation forte à y aller il y
aura personne qui le fera j'allais
prendre un parallèle hein si vous mettez
pour les collectivités dans une Galim
l'obligation de de tenir un certain
nombre de produits sous signe de qualité
mais qui a pas de sanction personne ne
fait et donc il me semble nécessaire
qu'il est peut-être pas une santion mais
au moins une incitation forte pour
toucher les aides publiques à avoir
suivi ce parcours et puis le dernier
point c'est que ce parcours euh on va
aussi devoir le faire différemment
notamment parce que par exemple quand on
installe quelqu'un qui est pas fils
d'agriculteur on a des sujets nouveaux
notamment le sujet du portage du capital
se traite totalement différemment que
quand on avait une installation
familiale où c'est les parents les
frères et sœurs qui portaient le capital
ce qui est déjà de moins en moins
accepté dans une famille euh et quand on
est plus issu du milieu agricole le
sujet du portage du capital et pas que
du capital pour le foncier le sujet du
portage du capital euh prend une
tournure totalement différente et on a
besoin d'un accompagnement majeur sur le
sujet même chose sur le sujet de la
formation où on a besoin d'angler la
formation sur des angles différents et
de plus en plus de faire de la formation
individuelle je pense que ce que prévoit
la la le la loi d'orientation sur ce
sujet-là est assez intéressant avec un
parcours individualisé de formation et
une analyse de projet quasiment
individualisé pour le le jeune puis le
dernier point qui est intéressant dans
cette loi d'orientation c'est aussi tout
le sujet de la
sensibilisation et de la communication
au grand public sur l'attractivité des
métiers agricoles et notamment un des
volets qui est avancé c'est celui de
rendre obligatoire quelque part pour
tout jeune en primaire une visite sur
une exploitation agricole ça nous semble
un sujet très intéressant parce que
voilà dans la génération de mes parents
pour vous donn un chiffre 80 % des gens
avaient un parent de niveau 2 donc un
cousin ou un oncle qui était agriculteur
dans la génération mes enfants c'est
moins de 5 % donc comment nos enfants
découvrent l'agriculture par les livres
d'images et quand on les invite à venir
sur l'exploitation les surprises sont
parfois grandes moi je reçois les élèves
de mon école et ils me demandent o
pourquoi il y a pas une vache un lapin
un chat un chien un cochon et cetera et
pourtant j'ai déjà un certain nombre
d'animaux sur la ferme donc ces visites
en primaire il faudra les faire de façon
très responsable pour donner des des
chiffres réels sur les métiers et pas en
faire de l'endoctrinement non plus dans
l'autre sens mais pour le coup ça me
semble une façon de recréer du lien
entre agriculture et société parce que
souvent quand on a vu les enfants on a
aussi des échanges avec les parents dans
les écoles qui sont intéressants
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président pour ces propos introductifs
et déjà extrêmement complet et précis
donc vous vous imaginez bien qu'on a
énormément de questions donc je vais
encore une fois vous demander si vous
pouvez être bref vous dispenser de
refaire un état des lieux et aller
directement à la question parce que
sinon nous n'arriverons pas à ce que les
uns et les autres puissent poser toutes
les questions que vous souhaitez donc on
va prendre les questions de Jean-Claude
tissau de Daniel salmon de Bernard buit
faites cour s'il vous plaît Jean-Claude
tu vas montrer l'exemple oui mais que je
m'entraîne quand même un peu mais il
faut quand même dire les choses moi je
d'abord merci pour vos votre
présentation je vourais quand même vous
nous précisiez bien j'ai l'impression
qu'on onite pas le même pays parce que
le les les les les manifestations qu'on
on a pu vivre les semaines dernières
tous les paysans que j'ai vu m'ont parlé
que de revenus revenus revenus et là
vous nous avez dit clairement que pour
vous c'était pas un problème de
trésorerie ni de revenu donc fa que vous
peut-être qu'on a mal compris mais j'ai
dit qu'il y avait un sujet il y avait
pas encore de problème de trésorie qu' y
avait un sujet de revenu et que ce sujet
de revenu était quand même beaucoup plus
criant dans le sud de la France que dans
le Nord ah j'ai pas compris ça mais
comme c'est enregistré on vérifiera
c'est pas grave dit OC voilà parce que
si c'est pas un problème de revenu à ce
moment-là mais ça
c'est euh euh ma première question en
fait c'est des questions très précis sur
une première question sur la filière du
lait avec des tensions qui sont
logiquement apparu avec les groupes
avancibl cage d'un usine la semaine
dernière et lactalice autour de la
question du prix d'achat 409 € les 1000
L de lait pour par savancia à cela
s'ajoute bien sûr des effets liés à la
décapitalisation du Chel de Bach letière
aussi j'aimerais connaître votre lecture
de la situation et des évolutions
potentielles de la filière lait est-ce
que le réseau des Chambres échange avec
ses industriels pour peser dans la
négociation des prix ou à minima
apportez-vous un soutien juridique pour
les procédures aux agriculteurs qui
essaient de faire respecter les
engagements des lois Galim et puis une
deuxième question rapide
en lien direct avec le premier le
président de la République a récemment
annoncé son souhait euh d'avoir un
égalim Européen pour s'attaquer aux
centrales d'achat européenne et ainsi
réellement influer sur la question du
prix est-ce que pour vous cette
proposition vous semble crédible merci
jean-cl d'avoir fait concis Daniel
salmon qui va faire de même oui bien
entendu merci madame la Présidente euh
de mots effectivement sur le revenu vous
êtes passé très brièvement pourtant ça
semble une question primordiale que
pensez-vous de la répartition de la pack
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas parlé aussi
des intermédiaires puisqu'on a
aujourd'hui des des enquêtes sur
Lactalis voilà le panier effectivement
de la ménagère ou du ménager le panier
alimentaire baisse mais comment se
fait-il que les prix continuent à
augmenter aussi de manière aussi
importante dans les magasins les phyo
effectivement ça vous vous en avez
beaucoup beaucoup parlé je viens
d'organiser lundi un colloque faisant le
parallèle entre la problématique de
laamante et celle des phyos avec les
mutualités c'est un danger certain qui
va mettre en qui va mettre en en
contradiction et en grosse difficulté
notre système de santé que pensez-vous
que l'agriculteur doit faire justement
pour aller vers une diminution de de ces
phyos il y avait de nombreuses victimes
des agriculteurs victimes des pesticides
des mères d'enfants victimes de cancer
pédiatrique à satepazane par
exemple que fait-on vous avez parlé de
des ha effectivement aujourd'hui on a
détruit encore 23000 km par an vous
parlez de les déplacer mais une ha ne se
déplace pas c'est de la compensation
peut-être qu'il faut faire mais comment
fait-on vous avez parlé du changement
climatique qui impacte l'Occitanie le
changement climatique va impacter toute
la France oui donc comment fait-on pour
vraiment lutter et comment l'agriculture
prend sa part dans cette lutte contre le
changement climatique merci Bernard buit
merci Madame le présidente monsieur le
Président le 1er février 2023 le Sénat a
adopté à l'unanimité la proposition de
loi du député Julien div visant à
calculer la retraite de base des non
salariés agricoles en fonction des 25
années d'assurance les plus avantageuses
le texte adopté par le Parlement en
février dernier prévoyait qu'un rapport
qui devait êtreis dans un délai 3 mois
précise les modalités de mise en œuvre
de la réforme à venir dans le respect
des spécificités du régime d'assurance
vieillesse des non salariés agricoles et
la garantie de niveau de pension des
droits qui ce rapport n'a été publié que
le 30 janvier et les scénarios proposés
feraient un certain nombre de perdants
en particulier chez les petites
retraites quel est votre regard sur ce
rapport avez-vous envisagé d'autres
pistes d'autres scénarios pour les
retraites des
nonsariés merci monsieur le Président je
vous laisse répondre à ces trois
interventions
alors sur le lait puisque c'était la
première interp déjà redire ce que j'ai
dit c'est qu'il y a pas encore de
problème de de trésorerie mais qu'
effffectivement je le redis on voit un
effet ciseau se faire et on voit des
coups de revient qui sont en train de
passer au-dessus des prix de vente donc
je je dis pas qu'il y a pas de sujet et
je dis que c'était plus criant dans
l'occitan ailleurs parce que le
changement climatique est plus client
dans l'Occitanie qu'ailleurs le sujet
dans le changement climatique qui touche
tout le monde il y a pas de débat
là-dessus euh sur le lait euh moi je
suis inérêt de voir que la France
deviendra au train où on est parti
importatrice de produits laitiers en
2007 2027 pardon
euh ça me laisse panti quand on voit la
capacité agricole de la France par
rapport à d'autres pays si nous on
devient importateur euh alors
effectivement il y a un sujet de revenu
derrière pas que il y a un sujet de
contrainte aussi du métier euh et pour
régler ce sujet de contrainte du métier
il faut accepter à un moment dans une
certaine mesure de permettre des
regroupements d'exploitation moi je suis
désolé mais on on ninstallera plus un
jeune avec 50 vaches deain parce que il
a pas les moyens de se faire remplacer
par contre on on installera probablement
des exploitations avec j'allais dire
deux associés et un salarié et 150
vaches c'est des modèles qui restent des
modèles à taille familial qui restent
des modèles à taille humain qu'on sait
gérer et et sur lesquels on a un partage
des astreinte qui peut permettre de
rendre les choses plus vivables juste
dire sur ce sujet là aussi de de
l'élevage
euh
vous côté Chambre d'Agriculture on
souhaite avec le ministère organiser un
certain nombre de débats un dans chaque
région pour mettre sur la table à la
fois les difficultés de l'élevage mais
aussi les aménités positives générées
par l'élevage et de de d'oser mettre sur
la table qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
maximiser ces ces aminités POS de
l'élevage qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
retrouver territoire par territoire une
dynamique autour de l'élevage et quelle
typologie d'élevage ou comment on
encourage des typologies d'élevage qui
ont ses aminités positives on est prêt à
poser ce débat et on voudrait trouver un
territoire pilote par région on voudrait
plutôt faire ça après le salon pour
essayer d'avoir ce débat et du coup
essayer de générer un peu un consensus
sur l'élevage parce que un des éléments
aussi dans la déprise de l'élevage c'est
l'image de l'élevage dans la population
des enfants d'éleveurs qui plus à
l'école qui sont fils de d'éleveurs ou
d'agriculteur et puis si si on dit il
faut maintenir l'élevage il faut qu'il y
ait une forme de consensus et que ce
soit pas le monde agricole qui disent
tout seul sur le sujet de la PAC moi je
sais pas quoi vous répondre il y a eu
des arbitrages sur la PAC qui ont été
discutés avec le ministère qui ont fait
un peu bouger les lignes qui ont essayé
euh parce qu'on peut pas donner des
grands coups de virage dans la pack qui
sont déstabiliser les choses et qui pour
moi ont pris en compte un certain nombre
d'enjeux économiqu de l'élevage et
notamment la pack actuelle elle a essayé
d'encourager les élevages qui créaient
de la valeur en maintenant et en gardant
les animaux le plus longtemps possible
sur l'élevage et notamment
l'engressissement pour conserver cette
valeur sur notre territoire plutôt que
de faire partir les animaux et je pense
que ça allit plutôt dans le bon sens
euh sur le sujet des phyos
euh je pense qu'un des points aussi
majeur si on veut que les agriculteurs
français progressent et les agriculteurs
européens c'est comment on arrive à
avancer sur les clauses miroirs et
comment on arrive à faire si on amène
des des des des des règles à
l'agriculteur français ou des ou des
choses que on Norte pas des produits qui
qui ne respectent pas les mêmes règles
et tant qu'on aura pas réglé ce sujet-là
je vois pas comment on pourra continuer
à pousser sous forme d'injonction les
agriculteurs français à améliorer leur
performance ceci d'autant plus que vous
savez comme moi que les règles
d'étiquetage rendent parfois un peu
compliqué de mettre en avant l'origine
du produit notamment quand on est en
restauration domicile et et du coup la
situation c'est au supermarché vous
trouvez quasiment du poulet français
parce que c'est écrit dessus l'origine
mais en restauration à domicile 70 % du
cas c'est du poulet qui est du poulet
d'importation et ça n'est jamais écrit
et je pense que aucun d'entre vous quand
il mange on mange tous du poulet non
français on en est jamais conscient donc
ce sujet des règles et ce sujet
d'étiquetage et les closuses miroir me
paraît majeur et puis le dernier point
sera aussi les règles dans les dans les
appels d'offre publ pour pouvoir
privilégier des produits locaux
notamment en tout cas nous on continue à
vouloir avancer sur l'enjeu de former
les agriculteurs sur ces sujetsl et de
de de les accompagner pour que chacun
ait son projet et je le redis on n'est
pas en train de refuser l'obstacle on
veut juste que c'est soit fait en
respectant des règles et notamment en
évitant de mettre d'un point de vue
économique l'agriculteur qui fait le
plus de progrès dans la situation
économique la plus difficile sur les
euh je je sais pas auokel moi je peux
entendre que la elle doit pas être
déplacée mais enfin un moment dans la
réalité d'une exploitation on peut être
amené à devoir la
déplacer non mais mais mais à un moment
moi j'ai un corps de ferme qui est voilà
entouré de Ha et cetera si je suis pas
capable d'élargir un peu l'entrée je
vais abandonner le corps de fer mais
refaire un bâtiment à côté je pense que
d'un point de vue environnemental c'est
pas tellement meilleur et en tout cas je
vais pas arracher et mon soit c'est pas
d'arracher des kilomètres de c'est de
pouvoir de temps en temps en déplacer en
la replantant en faisant des
compensations et à le faire simplement
enfin sur les r moi j'aimerait parce
qu'on on m'explique depuis des mois que
on arrache des 22000 km de ha en France
j'aimerait avoir la réalité sur les ha
agricoles arraché parce que dans le
cadre des déclarations pack nous ne
pouvons plus arracher de ha depuis un
certain
temps et donc je voudrais comprendre où
sont ces 22000 km de haie et je peux
vous dire que moi en tout cas en tant
qu'agriculteur je ne peux plus arracher
de Ha et j'en ai replanté depuis
quelques années c'est
comm voilà donc j'aimerais comprendre
ça sur le changement
climatique pour le
coup côté Chambre d'Agriculture avec la
la coopération on a portter un projet on
est en train de porter un projet
expérimental d'accompagnement des
agriculteurs face au Chang climatique et
sur à la fois sur les deux enjeux
adaptation et atténuation du changement
climatique où on va chez l'agriculteur
où oui on fait un bout diagnostic mais
on rédige avec l'agriculteur son plan
d'action pour qu'à la fois son
exploitation soit plus résiliante et
qu'il décarbone y compris en allant
jusqu'au sujet comment il valorise les
crédits carbones qu'il peut générer on
teste ça sur 1000 agriculteurs on forme
350 conseillers en 2024 sur le sujet
dans le but de pouvoir en faire de
pouvoir faire 10000 accompagnements à
part à partir de 2025 je le dis quand
même on a les financements pour faire
cette phase test en 2025 il y a pas de
financement prévu c'est ce que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure et donc en
2025 si le sujet c'est d'aller voir
l'agriculteur et lui dire si tu veux
être accompagné face au changement
climatique faut que tu fasse un chèque
de 1500 € on aura un succès d'estime
auprès des agriculteurs mais guerre
plus voilà et puis sur la retraite des
25 ans mon premier point c'est déjà
qu'on arrive à mettre en œuvre cette
réforme au plus vite y compris en
arrivant à calculer au plus vite les les
25 années des agriculteurs parce que
force de constater aujourd'hui que sur
le terrain nous on a Compain beaucoup
d'agriculteurs qui n'arrivent pas à
obtenir les chiffres sur le sujet donc
on se mobilise sur ce point-là après
oui on on a des trous dans la raquette
encore ce que vous évoqueiez et il
faudra probablement avancer sur ces
trous dans la raquette mais mais déjà
mettons en place cette réforme elle est
pas complètement mise en place
aujourd'hui he sur ce sujet-là une
proposition de loi a été déposée la
semaine dernière par Philippe Mouillet
et l'ensemble de nos collègues du groupe
LR pour justement régler le problème des
25 meilleures années des agriculteurs
donc on passe à trois nouvelles
questions rapides s'il vous plaît
Anne-Catherine Loisier Yannick Jadeau et
Serge
merilou merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président alors vous venez
de parler de l'élevage moi je je voulais
revenir sur ce sujet parce que c'est
quand même une catégorie d'agriculteurs
aussi en très grande difficulté moi je
je suis en Côte d'Or juste un témoignage
j'ai dans la partie bassin àéant je
rencontre quand même souvent des jeunes
agriculteurs qui comme vous l'avez dit
en fait sont en transmission mais ne
sont pas à mon sens suffisamment
accompagnés dans le gap qui doivent
faire ce que vous évoquz tout à l'heure
pour adapter leur leur exploitation aux
enjeux de l'avenir donc que que
pensez-vous mettre en place concrètement
enfin comment renforcer encore ce
travail que vous faites je le reconnais
mais peut-être pas suffisamment puisque
en fait quand on les interroge ils se
sent quand même seul et est relativement
abandonné sur dur jour sur le le sujet
de de l'élevage il y a en ce moment un
un dossier donc je je ne connais pas
forcément les tenants et les
aboutissants qui est celui du ratio
préie sur la SAU est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire quelques mots est-ce qu'il
y a effectivement un enjeu je crois
qu'il y a un enjeu entre les dates
proposées voilà par la profession et par
par le MAA et le MTS
euh et puis vous évoquiez le le le dans
ce contexte de surréglementation les
importations croissantes quelle est
votre analyse en fait du renversement de
de la logique égalime initiale qui a
été mise en œuvre je dirais par le la
dernière loi Bruno Le Maire dans le sens
où on on on sort de la logique de la
marche en avant du prix construction en
amont producteur industriel distributeur
par une pression qui s'exerce des
distributeurs sur la monde de la filière
pour obtenir hein ça a été dit et redit
des prix les plus bas possibles donc
est-ce que vous en mesurez aujourd'hui
les résultats ou quels sont vososos vos
préconisations pour l'avenir merci
beaucoup Anne-Catherine Yannick jado
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président bon je rajouter juste un petit
commentaire mais qui confirme quand même
sur la façon dont vous avez présenté les
la problématique de l'agriculture et de
la crise une sorte d'inversion de ce
qu'on a pu ressentir dans tous les
débats qu'on a pu avoir depuis des mois
avec les
agriculteurs leur principale
revendication c'est structurellement le
revenu et vous avez beaucoup porté sur
les questions de normes donc il y a
peut-être un petit décalage entre une
partie des agriculteurs et et ceux qui
les représentent mais trois questions si
vous me permettez
un qu'est-ce que vous on en est où il y
a eu le rapport travers potier à
l'Assemblée nationale sur la séparation
et la vente des produits phytosanitaires
par les Chambres d'agriculture disant
que cette loi égalim était peu et mal
appliquée quel est votre avis
aujourd'hui sur cette situation qui
évidemment nous ramène à la question des
phytosanitaires deuxème question vous
avez dit parfaitement l'idée
l'importance d'accompagner les
agriculteurs dans toutes les toutes les
transitions comme d'accompagner à
l'installation mais au fond est-ce que
ces sujetsl ne posent pas le problème du
ciblage des aides et de leur répartition
tant qu'on aura des aides à l'hectare de
fait qui privilégie par rapport à la
rémunération des services écosystémique
est-ce qu'on se retrouvera pas dans
cette même impasse d'avoir des jeunes
qui ont pas les moyens de récupérer des
des des exploitation qui ont tellement
grossi qu'ils ont pas les moyens et puis
au fond des paiements de services
écosystémiques qui sont relégué au fin
fond du 2ème pilier 3è question il y a
eu un rapport de la Cour des comptes
régionales des Pays de la Loire il y a
quelques mois mettant l'accent sur les
dangers et les risques de prélèvement
d'eau dans les Pays de la Loire et
pourtant il y a quelques jours la
Chambre d'Agriculture des Pays de la
Loire a demandé à ce que au fond on
mettre de côté toutes les études sur
l'eau est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
pas une contradiction forte aujourd'hui
au regard des préoccupations y compris
des habitantes et des habitants des PS
de la Loire merci Serge
meriloup madame la Présidente
monsieur le
Président les politiques agricoles des
des dernières décennies ont été bâtis
pour entraîner une montée en gamme des
produits français et c'est et c'est
louable et c'est c'est parfaitement
louable donc et c'est dans ce sens que
de de nombreuses normes
environnementales et sanitaires ont été
imposées aux agriculteurs
français et cela a mené une augmentation
considérable des coûts des produits
alimentaires en France et fait en sorte
que sur le marché les produits les
tomates marocaines ou les poulet
brésiliens et ukrainiens prennent la
place de nos propres
productions le résultat donc c'est que
les français et notamment les catégories
sociales les plus faibles ne peuvent
plus s'offfrir des produits de qualité
et et c'est ce que moi j'appelle la
première injustice c'est c'est-à-dire le
contenu de l'assiette et moi je suis
surpris que ce contenu de
l'assiette des catégories sociales les
plus défavorisé n'intéresse pas grand
monde parce que les catégories sociales
et c'est nous ici les plus favorisé
elles peuvent se payer ces produits là
et se pose pas la question de la façon
dont ça dont sont alimentés nos nos
compatriotes les plus défavorisés la
question Serge ben ma question c'est
comment pensez-vous comment selon vous
concilier nourriture de qualité et prix
accessible sans renier sur nos ex nos
exigences sociales environnemental et
sanitaire mais au fond est-ce que c'est
possible merci monsieur le Président
alors sur la partie élevage d'abord je
veux
euh confirmer avec vous que c'est quand
même le secteur agricole sur lequel le
sujet de revenu structurel est quand
même persistant depuis des années mais
je veux éviter de rentrer dans
l'opposition on commence à avoir des
zones de grande culture notamment dans
les zones intermédiaires où on a
exactement le même sujet donc attention
aux caricatures
voilà on a une déprise qui est
incroyable de l'élevage en ce moment en
France et si on fait rien ça se traduira
par une catastrophe environnementale
incroyable aussi hein
euh et donc quel quels sont les
solutions face à ça c'est reconnaître
les aménités positives de l'élevage
plutôt que mettre des contraintes tous
les ans un peu plus sur l'élevage et
accepter un certain nombre de voilà de
de de regroupement ou autre
euh juste sur l'accompagnement des
jeunes puisque c'était l'autre question
que vous posiez
euh je pense
que dans dans ce qu'on propose nous dans
dans ce futur parcours et et c'est
inclus dans la loi d'orientation
agricole cette notion de dans le projet
que porte le jeune regarder l'impact du
changement climatique notamment en
essayant avec des financement public
d'offrir aux jeunes la capacité à avoir
ce diagnostic qu'on est en train de
préparer de l'impact du changement
climatique sur l'exploitation et du coup
des changements que j'ai apportter sur
mon exploitation devrait être quasiment
fait dans toutes les exploitations pour
éviter que le jeune aille dans un modèle
et 5 ans après doivent réinvestir pour
changer des choses sur le modèle euh je
pense que dans l'accompagnement qu'on
essaie essaie de porter aussi on essaie
de développer des nouveaux sujets de
portage des capitaux et de portage du
foncier et on a des choses assez
nouvelles à aller imaginer avec des
portages du foncier qui
soi pacté à l'avance c'est-à-dire que
c'est pas un apporteur extérieur qui va
prendre départ et on recalculera la
valeur au moment de la sortie parce que
ça c'est très compliqué dans le monde
agricole qui a un peu trop l'habitude de
pas se rémunérer du travail du coup
l'entreprise prend de la valeur et à la
fin ben il partage quelque part le fruit
de son on travaille avec un autre
puisque sa rémunération qu'il a pas pris
il l'a mis dans la valeur de
l'entreprise mais avec des systèmes de
portage de fonciers
avec des taux
euh et et un PCT de sortie capé mais ça
repose quand même le sujet du revenu
parce qu'à un moment si on veut pouvoir
rémunérer le capital il faut avoir le
revenu en face pour rémunérer le capital
donc ça repose ce sujetl mais au moins
qu'on estit demain et et y compris des
fonds publics pour faire des garanties
autour du portage du foncier et des
portages du foncier pendant 10 ans pour
amener le jeune dans une période où il
pourra un peu plus facilement aller
chercher des remboursement
supplémentaire me paraît absolument
majeur euh voilà et puis le le le
dernier point c'est c'est avoir un
accompagnement très personnalisé du
jeune autour de sa formation parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a des arrivées de de
de parcours tellement diverses que ça
sert à rien de rammener tous les jeunes
dans la même formation et de dire c'est
ça le niveau obligatoire tout le monde
doit y passer le vrai enjeu c'est
comment je bouche les lacunes du jeune
qui peuvent dans un certain nombre de
cas être plutôt techniques dans d'autres
économiques et comme on fait un peu du
surmesure je reviens sur un point aussi
c'est attention on avait un truc qui
était dans le parcours à l'installation
qui est le stage 21h alors avec deux
aspects dans ce stage 21h qui était
peut-être le défilé des organisations
agricoles pour se présenter je suis pas
sûr que ça c'était complètement utile ou
au moins on pourrait le faire
différemment aujourd'hui mais il y avait
un côté très intéressant dans ce stage
21h c'est qu'on obligeait les jeunes à
être ensemble et à se présenter leurs
projets les uns les autres de manière à
les amener à voir ce qu'on fait les
autres et à avoir aussi des
connaissances d'autres agriculteurs qui
seront installés dans le même
département queeux et ça crée du
relationnel ça c'est c'est pas porté
dans la loi d'orientation agricole qui
est aujourd'hui c'est un peu l'oublier
essentiellement je pense pour des
raisons de financement mais si on fait
disparaître cet aspect
collectif je trouve que c'est
extrêmement dommage de pas au moment où
il s'installe amener cette ouverture
d'esprit et ce travail en collectif sur
le ratio
prairie il se trouve que je suis dans
une des régions les plus touchées donc
je connais le sujet premier point c'est
ce qui a amené aussi à à demander à
l'État de reculer la décision c'est
qu'on a besoin d'avoir des chiffres pour
comprendre puisqueaujourd'hui on calcule
un ratio prairie sur la surface agricole
et le pourcentage de prairie dans les
déclarations PAC mais il vous a pas
échappé qu'il y a une réforme de la PAC
entre deux et que on a des gens qui
déclaraient des choses à la PAC et qui
aujourd'hui ne déclare plus à la pâqu
notamment tout un tas de gens qui ont
passé les 67 ans qui avaient souvent
quelques hectares de prairies qui est
déclaré à la pâqu et aujourd'hui comme
ils peuvent plus la toucher il la
déclare plus à la pâac donc ces prairies
là ont disparu de la pâack ont dégradé
le ratio alors que pour autant les
prayers ont pas été retourné même sujet
sur la Normandie des éleveurs de chevaux
qui à un moment ont pensait pouvoir
toucher des aides de la PAC ont déclaré
leur prairies à la Pâque et aujourd'hui
ne touche plus donc ne décareent plus
leur prairie à la pâack donc on a besoin
d'avoir un la vérité sur les chiffres
pour comprendre non pas les ratios pques
mais la réalité des retournements
d'herbage après oui on a un vrai sujet
et je suis persuadé que retourner des
des herbages dans un certain nombre de
cas environnementalement parlant ça peut
être compliqué mais d'un autre côté
quand il y a pas le rentabilité
économique de l'élevage comment on force
l'agriculteur à maintenir de de de la
prairie donc il faut absolument qu'on
travaille ce
sujetl je pense que y compris sur le
sujet de la décarbonation par exemple et
et face au changement climatique euh
développer la prairie dans les
exploitations et l'herbe dans les
exploitations reste une solution très
intéressante sur lequelle nous on doit
conseiller les les agriculteurs mais
encore une fois c'est un accompagnement
au changement colossal et c'est aller
voir les mêmes agriculteurs qu'on a été
voir il y a 20 ans et qui qui on a
parfois dit de de faire du maïs parce
que il fallait produire plus de lait et
qu'on avait des enjeux de production
faut qu'on retourne les voir en disant
ben aujourd'hui il faut peut-être faire
un peu moins de maïs un peu plus d'Herb
mais je crois beaucoup plus en la
pédagogie pour le faire quand
l'injonction législative et cette
pédagogie et cet accompagnement on a
besoin de deux choses pour le montrer
aux agriculteurs des références
technicoéconomiques qu'on a gardé
peut-être dans la partie laitière qu'on
a abandonné dans beaucoup d'autres
secteurs qui permettent justement de
montrer qu'une exploitation qui a de
l'herbe si elle est conduite de telle et
telle façon ça reste aussi rentable que
voilà et on a besoin de développer ces
références pour guider et accompagner
les agriculteurs et on a besoin de
développer l'accompagnement des
agriculteurs tout courts qui je le redis
est devenu le paremp VI a des aides
colossales à l'investissement il y a
plus d'aide à l'accompagnement pour que
l'agriculteur bâtisse son propre projet
euh voilà
euh juste si peut-être un point aussi
qui a été très compliqué c'est les
mouvements de loi ou les mouvements
d'obligation sur j'ai le droit de
retourner j'ai pas le droit de retourner
je peux vous dire que dans mon
département ça a été délétaire une année
on disait tu as le droit de retourner tu
as plus le droit de retourner on disait
ah l'année prochaine tu vas avoir le
droit de retourner donc c'était un
signal un peu envoyé dépêche-toi de
retourner sinon c'est seras tu
ça a été quand même un peu compliqué et
le dernier point c'est moi je ne qui est
le traitement des prairies temporaires
de plus de 5 ans qui deviennent quelque
part des prairies permanentes dans les
déclarations PAC honnêtement ça c'est un
point que je ne comprends pas on a un
certain nombre de cas où avoir une
prairie dans une rotation c'est très
utile mais pouvoir la maintenir 7 ans
parce qu'au bout de 5 ans elle est
encore productive et donc ne pas la
retourner au bout de 5 ans serait assez
utile et je peux vous dire qu'en tout
cas nous si on veut convaincre des
agriculteurs de mettre des prairies dans
une rotation leur dire au bout de 5 ans
elle sera sanctuirisée c'est pas un
signal qui nous aide beaucoup et si on
savait leur dire ok si tu rajoutes des
herbages ils seront pas sanctuarisés il
y a pas d'enjeu autour de ça et tu
pourras même les laisser si ou 7 ans et
tu pourras le gérer comme il faut on
donne un signal pour refaire de l'herbe
en tout cas côté chambre on portera
parce que je suis persuadé que c'est
c'est un enjeu les agriculteurs pour les
accompagner au maintien de l'herbe voilà
euh si je continue sur la montée en
gamme
euh allez moi je vais peut-être évoquer
quand même un ou deux points je reviens
sur mon sujet l'étiquetage si on n pas
d'étiquetage comment on peut demander au
consommateur de faire un choix éclairé
quand il sait pas ce qu'il achète j'ai
juste souvenir ça va vous amuser mais
d'un contrôle voilà le monde agricole
aller regarder les étiquettes et un jour
la préfecture de rouan on a trouvé du
lapin et il était d'origine chinoise je
pense que si ça avait été marqué lapin
d'origine chinoise il y a pas beaucoup
de gens qui il l'aurait pris tout le
monde était persuadé y compris le chef
de servir du lapin français voilà
euh et et le dernier le dernier point
comment comment offrir à nos
concitoyens des produits de
qualité à un prix abordable d'abord je
voudrais redire
que l'écart entre les produits de
l'agriculture française de de qualité
est pas
toujours
colossal entre le le le produit de
qualité et et un produit d'importation
qui aurait pas forcément les mêmes
exigences le deuxième point c'est qu'on
a un petit sujet de la grande
distribution qui fait parfois sur des
produits pas chers des produits d'appel
où ils réduisent leur marge qui vient
creuser l'écart par rapport au produits
de qualité
euh mais je voudrais quand même dire ne
nous faisons pas d'illusion on peut pas
demander aux agriculteurs de monter en
gamme sans les payer plus cher question
ça a un coût c'est juste la réalité
donc après est-ce que c'est de
l'accompagnement public ou pas et puis à
la question de Monsieur jado sur que
j'ai oublié
sur sur la répartition sur la
répartition des adpac moi je pense que
on ne pourra faire monter les
agriculteurs en gamme pas uniquement
avec des soutiens publics je pense qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à créer les conditions
de marché qui font
que c'est viable économiquement moi si à
chaque agriculteur qui se convertit en
bio il faut mettre des aides
supplémentaires la pack ne suffira pas
donc à un moment voilà surtout quand la
consommation ne monte plus et de temps
en temps enfin moi j'ai j'ai pas de
problème pour dire il faut il faut que
par exemple en lait en ce moment en bio
on arrête les conversions pour
rééquilibrer le mar marché et si il faut
qu'on œuvre pour pousser le consommateur
à aller vers les produits bio et que dès
lors que la consommation redémarra on
redémara les conversions mais je ne
crois pas en une montée en gamme qui
tienne uniquement sur des aides
publiques je pense que ça n'est pas
viable et sur le sujet de l'eau dans les
Pays de Loire
euh je je
suis juste sur le sujet de l'eau moi je
fais déjà la différence entre de l'eau
qui est prélevée dans une app fréatique
profonde et de l'eau qui est prélevé
dans une rivière en période de cru et
euh quand même on a un sujet c'est le
niveau de détail et de ce qui est
demandé dans les études hchmuc
aujourd'hui qui sont les études qui
servent à faire des réserves sur lequel
on demande des études extrêmement
exhaustives et par exemple on demande
des études qui regardent comment on fait
pour maintenir y compris sur des cours
d'eau qui s'assèchent déjà l'été le
niveau d'eau dans le dans le cours d'eau
euh alors que l'agriculteur est prêt à
s'engager à ne pas prélever dans le
cours d'eau pendant ces périodes de
basse d'eau donc moi je je dis juste
qu'il faut qu'on arrive à simplifier les
choses et en tout cas on a un deuxième
sujet c'est que une fois que l'étude est
faite elle est systématiquement attaquée
au tribunal administratif euh parce que
les les le contenu de l'étude n'a été
défini nulle part et donc le point que
l'on porte c'est commençons par définir
le contenu de l'étude et on pense que
euh ces études étant quand même
probablement devant être fait très
différemment d'un territoire à l'autre
en fonction de type d'eau qu'on va
utiliser et cetera il me semble que ce
serait devrait-être du rôle du préfet de
définir ces éléments là avant qu'on
fasse des études dont le périmètre n'est
pas très bien défini merci merci merci
pas de réplique Patrick Chauvet
Sébastien plat et enri
ababanel merci madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président de votre
présence moi je voudrais vous nous
apportiez si vous le pouvez quelques
répones c'est nous nous venons au
travers de revendications légitimes euh
nous avons constaté que beaucoup de nos
concitoyens découvraient ce que vivaient
les agriculteurs et les agricultrices la
compassion suffira pas ma question est
comment on structure les réponses
comment on en fait une obligation de de
de résultat
et vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure sur
la filière laitière
euh le le seuil des effectifs d'élevage
euh moi je suis normand monsieur le
Président je l'ai évoqué la semaine
dernière on perd des élevages laitiers
dit j'ai j'ai des cas mais tout le monde
a et je les développerai pas de gens qui
viennent nous voir nous raconter ce
qu'ils vivent de jeunes agriculteurs qui
qui aspirent à une vie sociale légitime
parce que d'abord les vie de couple ont
changé enfin il y a plein de choses qui
ont changé j'ai un exemple de de trois
jeunes agriculteurs un J qui s'installe
l'entreprise qui collecte le lait et ça
c'est pas anodin qui commence à
s'inquiéter de sa ressource de collecte
propose aux jeunes de produire 150000 l
de plus il dépasse les 50 vach laitièr
ils en sont je crois à 20000 € de
dépense et ils vont abandonner donc
c'est pour mettre à la lumière et
rapidement les contr contradiction qu'il
a ma seconde question est
comment c'est encore une question de
structuration on a beaucoup parler
d'Europe c'est évident il y y a un sujet
sur l'Europe moi je voudrais qu'on
regarde
d'abord ce qui se passe en France
comment repositionner un ministère
comment aider le ministre quel qu'il
soit dans les gouvernements au
pluriel on a tous constaté des un
ministère affaibli qui commence et je
l'ai déjà dit par matcher à l'intérieur
du gouvernement parfois avant de
s'occuper de son propre ministère et
puis les injonctions contradictoires des
agences au pluriel on a tous des
exemples elles sont chacune dans leur
couloir je rappelle que c'est un service
d'état donc l'État a une obligation de
coordination de tout cela on peut pas
laisser les uns et les autres dire tout
et tout est son contraire la souffrance
qu'on a entendu
est parti de là parce qu'elle se
concrétise sur le terrain à un moment
donné donc comment on structure demain
euh tout ce qui a été révélé aujourd'hui
merci je voudrais en terminer madame
madame la Présidente quand même parce
que je l'ai évoqué la pire des choses ça
serait d'en rester là donc merci on
pourrait être beaucoup plus long mais
d'apporter des réponses monsieur le
Président sur ces questions de l'après
revendication merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président on va changer de
de culture et de Région va se rapprocher
à Méditerranée un peu crise géopolitique
alléa climatique sévère baisse de la
consommation concurrence déloyale
inflation attaque régulière des
lobbyistes antialcool loisvin
effondrement du marché bio empilement
des règles et des normes et usine à gaz
réglementaire bon j'en passe voilà à
quoi nous sommes confrontés en filière
viticole à la fois indépendant et et
coopérateur qui cumule à elle seul
l'ensemble je dis bien l'ensemble des
menaces qui pèsent sur l'agriculture de
notre pays alors aujourd'hui il faut
être inconscient sincèrement ou
insouciant pour se lancer dans ce type
de de culture preuve année les projets
d'installation s'effondrent je prends
l'exemple de chez moi dans le
département de l'ude l'an dernier zéro
installation en J zéro c'est la première
fois de l'histoire au moment où on se
parle le P deux seulement projets en
cours donc l'heure est grave diminution
des surfaces on vient de nous annoncer
100000 hactares d' rchat
supplémentaire je je vous dis hein ce
fluron de de notre agriculture est en
danger et vraiment sur la mauvaise pente
alors qu'il est porteur de valeur
ajoutée je vais pas je vais pas rentrer
dans les détails des chiffres mais doit
faire 17 milliards d'euros de chiffrees
d'affaires dans dans la base commerciale
française sur les 163 milliards d'euros
de déficit c'est quand même pas neutre
alors face à ce constat comment
jugez-vous les mesures de soutien à la
filière viticole annoncée par le
ministreagriculture la semaine dernière
et comment voyez-vous surtout l'avenir
de cette filière d'excellence merci
merci Sébastien hre Cabanel merci Madame
la la présidente merci Monsieur le le
Président j'aimerais revenir un instant
sur le revenu et et le fait qu'on est
mal interprété vous dire mais
ça m'étonne qu'à moitié parce que déjà
en 2021 quand on a rendu notre rapport
sur le mal-être des agriculteurs le
syndicat majoritaire n'était pas quand
même en phase sur le fait que ça soit le
revenu alors que nous avons visité des
départements euh et nous sommes pas
aller en Occitanie et tous les
départements que nous av nous avions
visité donc nous parlit déjà d'un
problème de de revenus justement par
rapport à ce revenu j'aimerais savoir ce
que vous pensez euh des paiements pour
services environnementaux
territorialisés euh le fait aussi
que beaucoup de de filières sont dans la
monoculture ne pensez-vous pas que les
chambes d'agriculture par territoire
devrait inciter donc à une
diversification justement pour permettre
donc aux exploitations d'être plus
résiliente et enfin donc dans la loi de
programmation agricole on va créer un
nouveau service France service
agriculture ne pensez-vous pas qu'avant
de créer un nouveau service il faille
donc mettre si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
le paquet sur la simplification parce
que pour en revenir sur une filière moi
aussi que je connais bien en viticulture
pour planter ou arracher il faut
informer le casier
viticole informatisé il faut informer
France arimè il faut informer le dossier
sur la PAC donc ça fait quand même
beaucoup de choses et et dernière
question par rapport donc aux nouvelles
responsabilités que vont vous donner à
travers la loi de programmation agricole
les nouvelles responsabilités que vont
assumer les Chambres d'agriculture
pensez-vous qu'il faille demander des
moyens supplémentaires pour les
chambres merci Henri monsieur le
Président si je peux vous demander
d'être assez concis dans vos réponses
pour qu'on puisse encore il y a encore
neuf questions après
alors juste j'ai oublié de répondre sur
la séparation conseil
vente
je
juste là où on est le le le rapport
potier travers et et à quoi est-ce qu'il
va donner une PPL je pense que c'est pas
moi qui peut répondre en tout cas dans
ce rapport il disait assez clairement
qu' voulait que le sujet du conseil
stratégique phito soit plutôt confié aux
chambres donc c'était dit noir sur blanc
de manière voilà en tout cas moi je je
suis persuadé d'un truc c'est que sur le
territoire il faut mobiliser tous les
acteurs et et il faut par exemple dans
une session de chambre si les COP ne siè
plus c'est la meilleure façon qu' ait
pas de lien avec eux et qu'on ne les
entraîne pas dans un mouvement global et
cohérent sur la réduction donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on continue à se parler
voilà après oui il doit y avoir des
limites dans la séparation et le rôle de
chacun je pense que ce qui était dans le
rapport potier travers il y avait une
forme de consensus et le monde agricole
était relativement prêt à l'accepter
maintenant est-ce qui donnera lieu
est-ce qu'il y aura une suite et et en
tout cas comment ça s'intégrera dans une
refonte écopyo CSP fait àoir mais en
tout cas je pense qu'il y avait un
consensus sur le sujet
euh sur les questions de de Patrick
Chauvet sur la simplification au-delà
des annonces qui ont été faites par le
Premier ministre on est en train de
regarder toutes les les les mesures de
simplification il nous apparaît qu'il y
en a quasiment la moitié qui sont
européennes mais qu'il y en a aussi
quasiment la moitié qui sont françaises
et celles qui sont françaises pour la
grande majorité elles nécessiteront de
passer par la loi
je vais reprendre mon exemple conseil
stratégique phyo dans la situation où on
est si on veut bouger il faudra passer
par la loi zone de non traitement si on
veut bouger les chos il faudra passer
par la loi
euh zone humide il faudra passer par la
loi y compris sur le sujet des si on
veut à un moment éviter l'amplilement
des réglementations il faudra passer par
la loi donc très peu de mesures sont des
mesures d'application locale qui seront
sous l'autorité du préfet donc au moins
côté chambre d'agricult ce qu'on essaie
de faire c'est on a listé toutes ces
mesures et on essaie de regarder comment
on les suit comment on suit leur
avancement pour maintenir j'allais dire
une Scine pression pour qu'on débouche
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets là pour
partir avant le salon parce que je pense
que plus on va traîner dans le temps
plus ce sera difficile de faire aboutir
ces sujets là pour parti dans le projet
de loi loi d'orientation agricole en
tout cas c'est les deux grands endroits
où on a imaginé de de pouvoir pousser un
certain nombre de changements et en tout
cas je peux vous assur
qu'on se mobilise pour suivre toutes les
annonces et regardz comment elles sont
mises en
[Musique]
place sur le sujet des agences alors
c'est un sujet dont le le Sénat s'était
déjà saisi il me
semble la cohérence entre les politiques
des agences et les politiques publiques
est absolument vitale si on veut
progresser encore une fois sur le
terrain on vit des trucs qui sont
incompréhensibles je vais prendre un
exemple en scène maritime comme ça
Patrick chauet qui a posé la question le
le comprendra voilà le sujet en scène
maritime sur la protection de l'eau
c'est le premier point c'est le sujet de
l'érosion puisqu'on est sur des zones
très érosives avec des des des betêtoirs
qui font de l'engouffrement très rapide
et donc si on veut éviter à la fois de
retrouver de la turbidité mais y compris
des phyos le point majeur c'est de
ralentir et d'éviter l'engouffrement
dans les bêtoires de l'eau et donc de
ralentir les flux d'eau pendant les
orages et de créer des zones
d'infiltration naturelles qui vont
filtrer parce que de toute façon même si
vous réduisez les phyos si vous avez un
engouffrement naturel vous en trouverez
systématiquement et bien l'Agence de
l'eau aujourd'hui sur ce territoire là
refuse d'accompagner les mesures qui ne
sont pas des mesures de réduction de
phyo et donc des mesures qui seraient
des mesures qui permettent d'éviter
l'infiltration et donc on est dans une
impasse sur ce sujet-l tout le monde
même la RS reconnaî sur le territoire
l'enjeu majeur y compris le maire du
Havre que vous connaissez aussi
reconnaissent que l'enjeu majeur c'est
de freiner l'engou ment dans ces zones
mais il y a pas de politique publique
parce que l'Agence de l'eau ne veut pas
ouvrir de politique publique sur ce
point-là c'est assez incompréhensible
euh
sur le sujet des des des PSE je vais
redire ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure je
pense que alors côté chambre on a poussé
quand même un certain nombre de mesures
de transition moi je crois pas en un
service environnemental qui vient se
substituer à une perte de revenu de
l'agriculteur dans la durée les MAE
telles qu'elles ont été écrites qui sont
des
compensation de de revenus à
l'agriculteur rend l'agriculteur encore
plus dépendant des aides et le jour où
elle s'arrête c'est compliqué et et on
l'a vu dans la dernière réforme de la
PAC dans un certain nombre de zones tous
les éleveurs qui avaient signé des MAE
nous disaient si je signe pas de Mae si
je je renouvelle pas Maes MAE je suis
mort et ceux qui en avaient pas signé
nous disaient il faut nous trouver une
enveloppe pour développer les MAE
l'équation est un peu compliquée à
résoudre et on avait poussé nous pour
développer des MAE de transition alors
là qui n'était plus géré au niveau
national qui était géré par les régions
dont le sujet était d'accompagner
l'agriculteur avec un accompagnement à
la prise de risque donc de l'aider
pendant 4 ans 5 ans sur une prise de
risque pour changer ses pratiques mais
qui soit décidé par l'agriculteur et pas
sur une trajectoire qui soit imposée le
seul problème c'est qu'on a eu du mal à
faire atterrir ces MAE là dans le cadre
réglementaire européen qui ne fait qu'en
réalité on ne peut payer que s'il y a
une perte de revenus alors nous on vous
vou une carotte financière qui
accompagne l'agriculteur à changer des
choses mais où il est à la fin dans une
situation économique qui soit au moins
équivalente à celle qu'il avait avant
pour pas devenir plus dépendant des
aides que par le passé mais où il est
amélioré son empreinte environnementale
et cetera et donc ça on y croit mais il
faudra débloquer le cadre européen pour
y arriver voilà et puis au sujet des des
budget chambre oui je remercie le
soutien qui a été apporté sur
l'augmentation cette année de du budget
des chambres d'agriculture qui avait
d'ailleurs été y compris soutenu par le
le syndicalisme agricole voilà et et le
soutien des 7,1 % qui avaient été porté
par l'Ensemble de de des groupes et qui
avaient été votés à l'unanimité donc je
remercie tous les acteurs qui étai
derrière j'en regarde quelques-uns au
passage euh mais mais c'est quand même
une des façons pour nous d'accompagner
les agriculteurs dans une situation
compliquée et et en tout cas je pense
pas que pour aider les agriculteurs dans
la transition baisser les moyens
d'accompagnement soit la
solution euh sur la filière viticolle
j'ai pas répondu euh voilà euh alors je
je peux à minima saluer les mesures
d'urgence qui était nécessaire
euh on a un certain nombre de zones où
il faudra porter des mesures
structurelles parce que c'est c'est des
situations qui se retourneront pas dans
les 3 ans ou 4 ans à venir et donc y
compris les sujets d'arrachage doivent
être mis euh sur la table euh le sujet
des des nouvelles technologies je pense
peut amener y compris dans la
viticulture demain des solutions
notamment sur les sujets phyau en ayant
des variétés plus résistantes et cetera
et amener des solutions je crois quand
même fortement la filière viticole qui
là aussi voilà façonne les paysages
français amène et crée de la valeur
quand même des les territoire même si la
situation est difficile et donc il faut
qu'on accompagne la viticulture dans
cette phase compliquée
pour pass ona pas Sansy public a pas de
sujet
làdessus question de habanel peut-être
puis après notamment laulture qui est
très impacté par le changement
climatique
PSE je pense que c'est ce que j'ai
répondu sur les et merci donc les
questions de Amel
ger
et présid monsieur président euh je vais
parler d'eau de nombreux rapports
alertent sur les risques de pénurie
d'eau et sur le stress hydrique le
rapport notamment de la mission
sénatoriale sur la gestion durable de
l'eau de 2023 avait pointé une baisse
des ressources en eau de 14 % en 30 ans
la sécheresse de l'été 2023 les
inondations notamment de fin 2024 début
de fin 2023 pardon début 2024 ont encore
démontré la menace du réchauffement
climatique sur sur ce point
deux questions un comment envisagez-vous
le risque hydrique pour l'année 2024
quel est votre investissement sur ce
point quel est votre accompagnement sur
ce point et est-ce que pour vous l'enjeu
est suffisamment considéré par l'État
merci merci Amel Daniel gremiller
oui merci madame la
Présidente trois questions la première
égalim égalim aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'on patine parce que on a des
indicateur qui tardent à arriver on est
avec soit un an de retard soit même plus
donc que peuvent faire les Chambres
d'agriculture pour avoir un indicateur
plus dynamique pourquoi égalim ne
fonctionne et ça le Sénat l'a dit depuis
le début ne peut fonctionner qu'en
période de déflation manque de chance la
déflation arrive en
202324 et pression sur les prix et on a
les indicateurs qui normalement aurait
dû permettre une augmentation qui sont
dans une situation de diminution puisque
on s'aperçoit qu'on est vraiment au
négatif sur les prix
2024 2è remarque euh c'est votre
position sur l'élevage je serais plus
prudent
euh la solution du regroupement au
niveau de l'élevage n'est pas la seule
solution je dis je seraai bien plus
prudent parce qu'on s'aperçoit et ça
c'est l'expérience aussi constaté que
lorsque vousoupez à 2 à 3 à 4 que vous
prenez une certaine taille votre
tentation de quitter l'élevage parce que
vous avez une Solle seré plus importante
est très grande et les constats montrent
que souvent c'est souvent les
exploitations de cette taille là et et
on peut être petit et et trouver il y a
peut-être d'autres formes je pense à des
salariés en commun tout en étant en
individuel à
réaliser je partage par contre une
question très concrète comment
expliquez-vous et quelle action mèent
les chambres pour arriver à combler
l'écart au mois de décembre l'écart
entre le prix le plus haut avec les
mêmes règles du jeu et le plus bas dans
la même entreprise c'est 100 € les 1000
l 100 € les 1000 l quelle action
concrète pensez-vous mettre en œuvre
donc il y a des choses concrètes à
ramener pour le le revenu des
agriculteurs je partage complètement le
propos sur l'herbe et je voudrais dire
aussi que de tout temps les paysans ont
été des bâtisseurs si on a des terrains
en terrasse c'est pas par l'opération du
Saint-Esprit c'est bien des paysans qui
ont fait ces terrasses si on a des talus
avec des roches c'est bien parce qu'il y
a des paysans qui ont été aménageurs et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est temps de
de redonner cette confiance et cette
capacité aux paysans aménageurs en
fonction des réalité dans les
territoires faisant leur confiance et
puis petite REM ou alors
j'arrête alors y blunven merci madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur winstor d'être
venu chez nous aujourd'hui Yv blunven
sénateur du morbillant trois questions
rapides la première sur le
renouvellement des générations je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ce que vous
dites c'est trop tard l'orientation 4e
3e faut travailler avant et en amont sur
la sensibilisation connaissez-vous
l'association outil en main mise en
place il y a une trentaine d'années par
les métiers de l'artisanat pour
sensibiliser les enfants de 9 à 12 ans
sur les métiers manuels il y a 250
ateliers qui fonctionnent tous les
mercredis en France je vous invite à
aller voir ce que c'est sur le morbillan
on fait une expérimentation et on
travaille avec les Chambres
d'agriculture pour sensib iser justement
C ces jeunes deuxème sujet LEZAN on est
dans le même
bateau vous n'êtes pas concerné dans la
première tranche de 10 ans par la
consommation des NAF notamment pour les
bâtiments d'élevage les seres et cetera
mais après 2031 vous serez comme nous
collectivité dans les mêmes obligations
là je pense aussi qu'à l'échelle d'une
région spécifique comme la Bretagne
comptenu des bâtiments d'élevage en
déséran abandonné qu'il y a sur des
quantités énormes de de de de s il
serait judicieux d'envisager avec la
chambre avec la Safire avec les 59epci
et la région portant la politique
économique de constituer une foncière
économique en pouvant chercher des
ressources pour renaturer ces friches
agricoles négocier des mesures
compensatoires mais ça ça passe par le
réglementaire et le législatif et
constituer des droits à construire sur
des zones d'activité voire sur des
exploitations parce qu'il y aura un vrai
enjeu consommation de foncier à la fois
pour vous agriculteur que pour nous
collectivité sur une activité économique
et dernière chose clause miroir euh
rapidement clause miroir euh c'est vrai
pour tout le monde on est tous d'accord
euh que pensez-vous des importations
massives d'engrais russes euh par un
circuit euh assez euh compliqué qui
rentre avec des quantités multiplié par
3 par 4 par 5 ces derniers mois et qui
nous oblige à fermer des
usines minéral azoté à Montoir de
Bretagne ou en charante merci Yve
monsieur le Président
euh alors euh question de l'eau la
question de l'eau qui a été la première
posée et que font les Chambres
d'agriculture sur ce sujet d'abord
redire que on est les premiers je
cherche ma voilà ma première partie de
note euh on accompagne la quasi-ttalité
des UGC donc de la gestion enfin même
pas la quasi la totalité des UGC côté
chambre le sujet de de gestion
collective de l'eau l'accompagnement des
agriculteurs pour partager les volumes
gérer les volumes et cetera donc je
pense qu'on est assez impliqué sur ce
sujet là le deuxième point sur lequel on
est très impliqué c'est avancer avec les
agriculteurs sur des mesures pour
économiser la quantité d'eau utilisée à
l'hectare par la modernisation des
installations par les pratiques et
cetera et les progrès qui ont été faits
sont colossaux enfin
euh on était en j'étais en
PACA pardon en région sud euh il y a
quelques temps
euh chez chez un agriculteur euh si on
compare les quantités d'eau qu'utilisait
son grand-père à l'hctar et les
quantités d'eau qu'il utilise
aujourd'hui à l'hctare pour faire des
tomates il y a un facteur 100 il y a un
facteur 100 sur la quantité d'eau
utilisée je dis pas qu'on est au bout il
faut continuer mais on fait cet
accompagnement là résolument le
troisième accompagnement qu'on essaie de
de faire c'est celui
sur la partie création de réserve mais
alors là euh on est euh on est dans
l'échec excepté dans les zones où il y a
déjà un historique d'irrigation encore
une fois quand vous êtes en région sud
avec une histoire de l'eau il y a une
acceptabilité de la gestion de l'eau
collective qui est réelle dans les
autres régions ça n'est pas le cas y
compris et encore une fois moi j'ai j'ai
pas de sujet pour dire euh il faut être
très vigilant sur les moi je suis en
scène maritime sur des nap créatique
profonde et et surveiller le
rechargement de saénap et cetera est un
enjeu majeur et et utiliser l'eau à
bonciant pour éviter de de descendre le
niveau de saénap est un enjeu majeur
mais à l'inverse s'interdire de prélever
de l'eau sur des ruisseaux qui sont en
cru me pose quelques questions et en
tout cas on est un peu dans l'impass
dans un certain nombre de zones où on
fera plus d'agriculture sans eau il faut
quand même pas se leurer et se raconter
des histoires sur égalim alors quels
indicateurs peuvent suivre les chambres
euh je je pense que le premier rôle des
chambres il est plutôt de de commencer à
suivre des indicateurs sur les enjeux de
souveraineté ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on
fait voilà sur les les les pertes de
souveraineté et cetera sur le sujet des
prix j'entends la question et je pense
que c'est important de l'avir mais
jusqu'alors c'était plutôt le
syndicalisme agricole qui portait ce
sujet de relevé de prix et cetera donc
j'entends la question il faut
probablement le réactiver est-ce que
c'est un rôle que doivent porter les
chambres
okok le débat mérite d'être posé en tout
cas il faut un organisme nutre
et et et il y avait aussi un organisme
qui avait été créé par l'État
l'Observatoire des prix et des marges
[Musique]
ouais mais le problème c'est qu'il faut
le réformer pour le faire fonctionner
parce que si c'est les chambres qui le
font va être accusé je le dis très
clairement de de de porter une vision
qui est celle de la défense du monde
agricole et voilà mais j'entends la
question j'ai pas de réponse à amener
comme ça euh alors oui mes propos on été
un peu caricatural sur le regroupement
des exploitations ce que je voulais dire
c'est que le premier enjeu qu'on doit
travailler alors il y a deux enjeux il y
a le sujet du revenu quand même parce
que c'est un peu plus facile d'accepter
des contraintes quand on en tire un
revenu réel et le deuxième sujet c'est
celui de la pénbilité et des contraintes
du travail c'est ce que je voulais
illustrer par mes propos y compris côté
chambre pour accompagner des mes
autour de l'accompagnement à de
l'investissement qui va minimiser la
pénibilité de l'élevage pour
l'agriculteur voilà et et bien sûr on
continue à accompagner assez fortement
les sujets c'est moi-même mon cas de
salariers portés dans des groupements
d'employeurs de solutions de
remplacement et cetera voilà et je voilà
et
puis alors qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire par RA rapport à à l'actalis
ou ou autre on a un sujet comme d'autres
acteurs c'est un moment qu'on n pas
complètement le droit de s'yimisser dans
les relations commerciales le seul
soutien qu'on peut faire un peu
réellement c'est de soutenir la création
d'organisations de producteurs qui sont
en capacité de négocier et de leur
apporter notre soutien notamment ce
qu'on essaie de faire depuis quelques
mois par la cellule économique des
chambres d'agriculture c'est de leur
amener des éléments sur l'évolution des
coup de revient sur l'évolution des
volumes de production et cetera qui leur
donent des armes pour négocier mais on n
pas le droit de se mettre en lieu et
plac des organisation de producteurs
dans ces négociations
euh alors il y a eu ont été évoqué à
nouveau le sujet des des stages je le
redis nous on essaie de développer et on
travaille alors si vous vous avez parlé
de
euh de d'outils en main alors on connaît
enfin on connaît assez bien l'initiative
on a beaucoup discuté avec les CCI qui
ont fait un travail remarquable sur
l'image aussi bien par ça que par leur
campagne de communication commune à un
moment
euh donc on est on a un certain nombre
de discussions avec eux et en fait on
est aussi en train de faire un
inventaire de ce qui se fait dans le
monde agricole parce qu'on a un certain
nombre de territoires français où il se
fait des choses et j'étais hier soir
encore en discussion avec le le la
Direction Générale de l'Enseignement et
de la Recherche du Ministère de
l'Agriculture pour regarder justement
comment on peut s'appuyer sur des
initiatives qui existent déjà localement
sans aller complètement réinventer les
chos pour généraliser cet accueil de
jeunes dans des des des formations
primaires sur des exploitations
agricoles donc le sujet est embarqué il
y aura un petit sujet de financement à
un moment mais le sujet est embarqué et
dans la loi
d'orientation sur le zéro artifici le
zéro le zan voilà
euh
euh peut-être revenir sur deux points
d'abord je le redis à un moment un fond
de portage restera un sujet majeur
euh je je crois aussi en l'utilisation
de de fonds de compensation pour
justement porter un certain nombre de
projets là on a un petit point c'est que
dans la loi pour enfin pour un
organisme un aménageur qui va prélever
du foncier en théorie il est obligé de
cotiser et de payer une c certaine somme
pour compenser la perte d'activité
économique agricole que génère la la le
prélèvement sur le terrain de de ce
terrain il se trouve que aujourd'hui on
a un peu de mal à faire décoller ces
sujets là parce qu'il y a un certain
nombre d'aménageurs qui passent à côté
et qui a pas vraiment de sanction et que
le seul qui peut un peu mettre la
pression c'est le préfet donc écrire des
sanctions serait pour moi prévoir des
sanctions pour les aménageurs serait
pour moi assez utile pour que la loi
s'applique et le deuxième point
ben les aménageurs pour un certain
nombre aimeraient bien gérer tout seul
ou gérer tout seul avec la collectivité
local ce sujet de la compensation
agricole nous on demande à ce que quand
même les Chambres d'agriculture soient
un peu dans la boucle pour qu'on fasse
pas n'importe quoi et là aussi ça nous
aiderait si on écrivait le cadre et on
est prêt à en discuter on demande pas à
être les seuls à le faire bien sûr faut
que ce soit fait avec les collectivités
locales mais on demanderait à ce que le
cadre de la gestion de ces fonds de
compensation soit peut-être un peu
clarifié et un
peu régulé voilà et c'est un sujet sur
lequel on est prêt à échanger avec vous
et il nous semblerait utile à un moment
de pouvoir porter un projet merci Sophie
prima Frédéric Buval et Christian
redonarazi merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président moi j'ai une
question qui revient souvent dans la
bouche des agriculteurs qui est la
commande publique les collectivités ne
font pas ce qu'elles doivent faire et
qui est inscrit dans la loi égalime vous
l'avez dit vous-même tout à l'heure les
50 % de produits sous qualité les 20 %
de bio la difficulté majeure que
rencontrent les collectivités locales
qui sont très àentes sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs au-delà même des questions de
prix qui peuvent se poser c'est la
structuration des filières parce qu'en
réalité c'est gentil quand il y a des
petites écoles de campagne qui font qui
font 25 repas par jour là c'est pas très
compliqué quand vous êtes en région
parisienne et que vous avez des millions
de repas scolaires à à délivrer chaque
année dans une région qui n'est pas très
agricole et dans la variété de
production n'est pas avérée il faut des
filières d'organisation il faut de
logistique de production de regroupement
pardon de dire ça mais de grossiste
agricole je sais pas comment les faire
quel est le rôle des chambres comment
est-ce que les chambres peuvent
accompagner parce que très honnêtement
je pense que le problème n'est pas dans
la volonté la problème le problème est
dans la réalisation et l'exécution des
choses et souvent les collectivités se
trouvent un peu
embêté avec ça et les exemples qu'on
nous montre y compris à la télévision
ils concernent un ou deux produits pas
plus merci som Sophie Frédéric Buval
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
Président je souhaite vous interroger
sur les éour mire alors l'agriculture
est un pilier essentiel de l'économie de
territoire ultramarin et elle est
confronté à des défis
multiples la question du revenu agricole
est cruciale l'adaptation aux nouvelles
réglementation environnementale et
sociale est un enjeu majeur pour
l'agriculture à notre maire éloignement
et insularité insularité constituent des
contraintes supplémentaire pour les
agriculteurs ultramarins accompagner les
agriculteurs ultramarins est donc
fondamental or les Chambres
d'agriculture notre mè du fait de leur
mode de financement ne peuvent seul
répondre à toutes ces problématiques à
alors qu'elles sont les principaux
interlocuteurs identifi par les
agricultteurs je aussi pouvez-vous
m'indiquer comment selon vous il serait
possible de mieux prendre en compte les
difficultés des agriculteurs et des
chambres d'agriculture en notre j'ai
fais cour madame la président très bien
merci beaucoup chisan r merci madame la
Présidente président moi je souhaitais
vous interroger sur un sujet qui a été
peu évoqué dans dans la période
tumultueuse que l'on vient de traverser
le sujet des
énergies notamment agrivoltaïsme
méthanisation quand on met ce ce sujet
en regard des difficultés d'installation
de la pression sur le foncier que cela
peut générer quand on le met aussi en
regarde de l'autonomie alimentaire que
l'on
promeut il y a quand même un sujet euh
je voulais savoir quelle était
aujourd'hui la position euh des chambres
là-dessus euh et en particulier moi je
suis dans Z territoire la haut viienne
où la Chambre d'Agriculture euh soutient
sans retenu tous les projets euh de
développement de métanisation d'AG de
voltaï de photovoltaïque enfin
d'agrivoltaïsme ce qui quand même quand
on
le ramène à aux échanges qu'on a pu
avoir ces dernières semaines et et est
assez contradictoire parfois
merci monsieur le Président pour
répondre à ces trois interventions et
après on aura encore quatre questions et
on vous libérera
alors sur la structuration des
filières je veux quand même
oui il y a un sujet de structuration des
filières mais enfin il y a quand même
des filières qui sont organisées
aujourd'hui une collectivité qui veut
acheter des produits laitiers bio ou de
la viande bio il y a des filières très
organisés qui
peuvent alors voilà même même signe de
qualité euh euh je pense qu'à rangis il
y a une offre assez significative
aujourd'hui de produits y compris
fléchés locaux maintenant c'est vrai que
le le sujet principal qu'on a c'est sur
tous les produits qui sont distribués
c'est c'est plus qu'un sujet de de
filière c'est un sujet du dernier
kilomètre de la logistique qui est
extrêmement cher et et plus qu'un sujet
de filière c'est comment on arrive à
mutualiser justement entre les produits
sous signe de qualité et ceux qu'il sont
pas et là on a un vrai sujet d'arriver à
embarquer les acteurs de la logistique
je vais donner un nom Pomona par exemple
sur le fait que dans leur offre ils
aient conjointement des produits sous
signe de qualité des produits locaux et
cetera et ça c'est un point sur lequel
on bute un peu aujourd'hui euh voilà et
on y arrivera que par une pression des
deux côtés nous du monde agricole pour
essayer de de les convaincre et une
pression de leurs acheteurs qui vont
dire à un moment mais si vous l'offrez
pas on va aller voir ailleurs quoi je
vois pas beaucoup d'autres solutions bah
il y a il y a quand même de trois il y a
quand même de trois acteurs sur le
marché mais c'est compliqué et et c'est
même parfois euh encore plus compliqué
dans les petites communes parce que ce
sujet de la logistique à l'unité il
coûte encore plus cher et j'allais dire
même quand il y a un agriculteur à 20 km
il va pas les livrer pour 25 repas des
yaourt donc la seule solution c'est de
mutualiser les outils de mutualiser les
outils de distribution notamment sur
voilà alors on a eu des tentatives he
pour créer des plateformes logistiques
sur des chambres et cetera mais en fait
on tient pas le modèle mod économique
parce qu'encore une fois on veut faire
des plateformes logistiques qui sont
destiné qu'au produits aux produits
locaux et si on veut tenir les
plateformes logistiques il faut les
mutualiser avec d'autres produits il
faut pousser les acteurs alors est-ce
qu'on peut le faire dans la loi je je
vois pas bien ça mais enfin en tout cas
moi je crois pas à la loi qui oblige
voilà après ce que j'ai dit avant sur
les obligations du monde agricole voilà
je crois plutôt à la pression des
collectivités il y a des choses qui
commencent à bouger quand même je
parlais de Pomona tout à l'heure il
commence à développer un peu dans le des
sujets de de de circuit court le sujet
c'est aussi que les grands acteurs de
l'achat parce qu'en fait le sujet plus
que les collectivités ceux qui ont un
vra moyen et qui portent des gros
volumes c'est parfois les lycées et
cetera et là on a un travail à faire
qu'on fait avec les régions pour mettre
les pressions et et ça bouge quand même
voilà moi ça bouge quand même on peut
pas dire qu'il se fait rien
oui
ok j'ai un autre truc que j'ai écrit que
j'arrive pas à
relire c'est pas grave sur les outres m
alors merci de la question parce que je
pense
que depuis mon arrivée on peut m'accuser
de plein de choses mais pas de n'avoir
rien fait pour les outres mèes la hausse
de 7,1 % que vous avez voté et que vous
avez voilà on ne l'a pas réparti
linéairement sur les chambres et je peux
vous dire que quand j'ai dit aux
chambres on va pas répartir linéairement
sur tout le monde j'ai eu un certain
nombre de chambre d'c qui sont monté au
créneau qui étaient pas d'accord avec ça
mais la réalité c'est quasiment toutes
les chambres d'outremè vont voir qu'il y
avait un niveau d'impôt plus bas vont
voir leur impôt monter de 15
% quand un certain nombre d'autres neous
le verrons augmenter que de 5 % donc
premier point on a essayer de corriger
ça et et ça sera actif dès 2025 et on a
fait 15 % pourquoi on n pas allé au-delà
puisque dans la loi on n pas le droit
d'aller au-delà de 15 % d'augmentation
là aussi je pense pour préserver aussi
le contribuable out premaire agriculteur
d'un autre côté d'une hausse qui serait
exagérée mais en tout cas on a pris le
taureau par les cornes deuxième point
euh j'ai fait voter une enveloppe de
solidarité de près de 2 millions financé
par les autres chambres pour financer la
montée en compétence des chambres
d'outremè sur les outils numériques
parce que on avait trop long laissé ces
chambresl un peu de côté elles
utilisaient pas les mêmes outils et donc
on est en train de le ramener tous les
outils de conseil les outils de gestion
financière les outils de traçabilité de
l'utilisation de l'impôt les outils RH
et cetera on est en train de leuramener
tous les tous les mêmes outils que le
reste du réseau donc très honnêtement je
pense qu'on a un peu pris le le taureau
par les cornes sur le sujet et puis le
dernier point c'est qu'on a une cellule
d'accompagnement des chambres d'outremè
qui à mon arrivée était daté de d'un
tiers de TP et qui aujourd'hui a
quasiment 4 TP pour accompagner les
chambres d'outremè donc je pense qu'on a
fait un travail et je suis convaincu que
il faut que les chambres d'outr-emè
fassent le même boulot que les autres
chambres après c'est compliqué parce que
parfois on a des oppositions de
filièrees dans les outres mers que vous
connaissez bien et la Chambre a parfois
du mal à trouver sa place voilà et puis
sur l'énergie
alors d'abord il vous a pas échappé que
je maîtrise pas complètement les choses
dans la Vienne euh
ou dans la Haute Vienne mais c'est
pareil
euh mon point de vue c'est quand même
que à un moment où on parle d'
décarbonation on ne fera pas le
décarbonation donc où on va dire on va
arrêter de puiser dans l'énergie fossile
sans demander à l'agriculture de faire
une partie des de cette production
d'énergie le vrai sujet c'est de de
trouver des équilibres parce que ça va
venir perturber les équilibres et il est
pas possible que ça se fasse au
détriment de la production alimentaire
donc l'enjeu c'est comment on accompagne
l'agriculture à produire plus sans
ou en continuant à améliorer son
empreinte environnementale comment on
arrive à produire plus et arriver à
trouver des équilibre entre la
production alimentaire et la production
énergétique pour être très concret et
donner des réponses concrètes à ce que
vous m'avez dit sur la méthanisation je
pense que développer la méthanisation
des effluant d'élevage c'est un sujet
majeur à une période où on est dépend de
l'énergie de de l'extérieur il faut
développer la production de
méthanisation à partir des effluant
d'élevage mais je dis bien à partir des
effluents d'élevage je pense que pour
faire tourner des des méthaniseurs on
est parfois obligé d'y mettre 10 % de ou
15 % de culture dédiée il faut surtout
pas monter au-delà de ce chiffre là ça
me paraît majeur le deuxième point et
j'en ai beaucoup discuté avec mon prég
région c'est que il faut qu'on contrôle
ça pour éviter les abus parce que
parfois on a quelques abus qui donnent
une mauvaise image à tout le monde et le
troisième point c'est qu'à un moment si
on veut développer la méthanisation
autour des effluant d'élevage il faudra
aussi qu'on accepte peut-être d'aller
plus loin dans la différenciation des
tarifs et notamment sur de la petite
méthanisation des tarifs nettement plus
élevés pour développer de la petite
méthanisation ou de la méthanisation
voilà notamment je je prends euh des des
des zones par exemple dans le centre de
la France où on n'ira pas créer des méga
méthaniseurs si on veut y arriver il
faudra des petits méthan collé à
l'exploitation qui valorise les effluant
d'élevage et on ne pourra pas le faire
avec des tarifs de rachat identiques si
on a des gros méthaniseurs qui sont
comme chez moi installés à la sortie de
la sucrerie et qui passent la moitié ou
les 2/ers des pulpes de la sucrerie dans
le méthaniseur ouais ouais mais qui du
coup d'un point de vue compétitivité et
incomparablement donc il faudra voilà en
tout cas la position des chambres c'est
de soutenir la mécanisation à capitaux
agrico à capitaux agricole et pas des
modèles de gros méthaniseurs comme celui
que je viens de de citer euh et le
deuxième point c'est d'arriver à
différencier et à mettre des aides
publiques quelque part ou sur
l'investissement ou sur les tarifs de
rachat pour développer de la petite
métallisation il y a des exemples assez
intéressants qui se sont faits en
Bretagne ils sont pas forcément
copiables ailleurs mais la Bretagne au
travers de des procédés nénuar arrive à
chauffer les élevages avec les gaz émis
de l'élevage ça me semble assez vertueux
et puis deuxième sujet le le le
photovoltaï au sol et l'agrivoltaïsme
deux points le photovoltaïque au sol
déjà pour nous c'est pas sur des terres
agricoles le photo photovoltaïque au sol
n'est acceptable que sur des terres
improductives et pas improductif parce
qu'il y a un débat entre les deux
héritiers et qu'elles sont délaissées
mais des terres réellement impropres à
la culture et donc pas de photovoltaïque
au sol sur des
terres ouvertes et ouvrant la
possibilité à la culture et sur
l'agrivoltaïsme pour le coup on a pris
les positions nationales très claires
sur le sujet c'est un il faut continuer
et avoir des expérimentations pour avoir
des références et comprendre l'impact de
de l'agrivoltaï sur les cultures qui
sont dessous de et donc pas développer
des projets si on ne connaît pas
l'impact ou si on n pas maîtrisé
l'impact de développer des projets si on
est capable d'assurer qu'il aura moins
de 10 % et c'est ce qui est dans le
texte de loi dans la loi énergie s'il y
aura s'il y a moins de 10 % de perte de
production et troisième point euh tout
ça se décidera au CDP NAF il me semble
que c'est l'intelligence locale qui doit
aussi permettre de faire le tri entre
les projets à liby et les projets voilà
est-ce que nous on prône côté Chambre
d'Agriculture c'est un développement
raisonné avec un maximum à définir par
chaque département mais inférieur à 5 MW
de production par agriculteur de manière
à ce qu'on voit pas des projets de 70
hectares chez un agriculteur et pas plus
de 200 MW par département en 2025 de
manière à amener un développement mesuré
et modéré de de la agoltaïsme et en tout
cas d'être très vigilant à ce qui est un
système de sanction quand on a de
l'agrivoltaïsme et qui a plus de
production
deessous mais en tout
cas le sujet c'est pas d'autoriser 40 %
et si vous regardez comment le texte est
rédigé c'est maximum 40 % mais notre
règle notre règle et la règle qui doit
valoir en CDP NAF c'est pas plus de 10 %
de perte de production avec des essais
qui ont été faits et qui montrent qu'on
a bien pas plus de 10 % de perte de
produ
et en tout CDP
CDP en tout cas en CDP NAF nous on sera
et et et le sujet c'est que ces
doctrines elle soit partagé à l'échelle
de chaque département y compris avec les
collectivités et le préfet de manière à
ce qu'on arrive à se fixer des règles
sur les projets qu'on accepte ou qu'on
accepte pas mais en tout cas le sujet
c'est pas d'ouvrir à 40 % partout il y a
des tas de cas où à 40 % va générer
largement plus de 10 % de perte et donc
ces projets là il est pas question de
les accepter et notamment laadem doit
fournir à partir des projets
expérimentaux et des références des des
des des tableaux indiquant sur tel type
de de d'agrivoltaïsme on ne doit pas
aller au 40 % parce qu'on générait plus
de 10 % de perte merci alors on va
essayer de ne pas trop déborder par
rapport à l'audition qui suit donc les
question de Franck Menonville Rémy
Cardon Eveline corbineinzo et Laurent
Duplomb très rapidement s'il vous plaît
très rapidement madame la Présidente
Monsieur le
Président wi deux deux questions
extrêmement rapides lesf la première
concerne la la mise en veille du plan
écofyo quelle est votre analyse et
surtout quelle initiative souhaite
prendre les Chambres d'agriculture parce
que je crois que vous avez un rôle
potentiellement central parce que on le
voit bien ce plan
écopyo n'a pas n'a pas fonctionné
surtout sur un certain nombre de points
de la baisse des produits
phytosanitaires ne se décrète ne se
décrète pas au travers une trajectoire
et des chiffres et des objectifs ça se
construit ça se construit par la
promotion de de solutions la promotion
de de
l'innovation et donc et parmi les
éléments vertueux de C de ce plan écopyo
je crois que c'était les les fermes
défis et vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure comment donc faire des
propositions merci construite et le
deuxième peut-être c'est le sur le le le
guichet unique de France service
agriculture quelle est votre analyse sur
cette future organisation et quel rôle
ambitionnent les les chambres dit ir
merci Rémy Cardon merci madame la
Présidente étant donné que j'avais posé
la question au président de la FNSA sur
la question du du revenu des
agriculteurs en particulier euh moi
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur le cas
très précis du plafonnement des marges
de la grande distribution est-ce que
vous le revendiquez étant donné que je
sais que les chambres ont pour objectif
de contribuer à l'amélioration de la
performance économique sociale et
environnemental des des exploitations
agricoles je m'interroge si vous avez
une position est-ce que vous le
revendiquez on voit un alignement des
prix entre la production agricole et et
les marges brutes euh est-ce qu'il
serait temps de s'en occuper voilà merci
Eveline corbiard
naminzo merci euh merci madame la
Présidente euh je vais faire court
également je vais d'abord me placer du
point de vue des des agriculteurs je je
suis donc un peu plus fort Eveline s'il
te plaît oui alors je vais me rapprocher
voilà je suis donc sénatrice de la
Réunion et donc ma question va porter
sur l'agriculture en outreem
euh alors dans vos propos en début de
d'audition vous disiez que la trésorerie
n'était pas un
problème au contraire c'est
principalement ce qui a
motivé la mobilisation des agriculteurs
à la réunion après échange avec
plusieurs d'entre eux je me permets de
vous rapporter un de ces un de ces
propos qui dit que donc c'est un éleveur
de poulet et une fois qu'il a élevé le
poulet qu'il est passé à la B étiqueté
sous emballage en grande surface
celui-ci ne lui est plus accessible en
gros c'est trop cher par rapport au
revenu qu'il perçoit de son exploitation
et ce qu' lui reste à faire c'est de se
rabattre sur les poulets de dégagement
de l'Union européenne voilà pour la
question de la
trésorerie moi j'ai une autre question
qui porte sur le changement climatique
et on l'a vu là sur ce début d'année
2024 le changement climatique il impacte
lourdement
les outrmers et principalement au niveau
de
l'agriculture après le cyclone Béal on a
pu constater les
dégâts
comment vous
pourriez préciser l'accompagnement qui
qu'on pourrait imaginer pour les
agriculteurs en Outremer quand on voit
simplement regard du risque cyclonique
que la trajectoire des cyclones a dévié
nous plaçant sur la route des cyclones
et quand on voit
l'intensité évidente des phénomènes
qui qui qui
augmente le dernier point juste un
dernier point c'est quelle proposition
pourriez-vous faire quant à la recherche
parce que localement nous avons une un
cade performant et là l'agriculteur
participe de façon très volontaire à
améliorer la connaissance et la
recherche en la matière il n'en profite
pas ça ne il n'en voit pas les retomber
sur sa production bien au contraire ce
sont nos connaissances notre technicité
qui est qui est exporté à l'étranger et
nous subissons du même coup la
concurrence déloyal des produits
étrangers merci merci Laurent Duplan
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de des Chambres d'Agriculture
de France je voudrais revenir sur la
question du revenu puisque souvent ce
qui nous est opposé aujourd'hui c'est le
revenu avec un exemple lundi j'étais
dans un commerce multi multirural qui
don la la personne qui le tenait
m'expliquait que pour faire 900 € de
revenus elle av un chiffre d'affair de
130000 € alors vous allez comprendre le
sens de ma question aujourd'hui le Rica
qui correspond au recensement comptable
des exploitations agricoles nous dit que
sur 390000 exploitations en France
exploitation 125000 font un chiffre
d'affaires annuel inférieur à 25000 €.
alors je me dis une épisserie qui a
besoin de faire 130000 € pour faire 900
€ de revenus comment un agriculteur
sodisant so-disant agriculteur qui avec
25000 € de chiffre d'affair peut ne pas
se plainre de son revenu est-ce que vous
croyez qu'à un moment donné nous n'avons
pas installé beaucoup trop
d'agriculteurs qui n'avaient absolument
aucun projet économique et qui ont été
des installation entre guillemets
dogmati et qui font qu'aujourd'hui ces
installations là on les retrouve comme
étant ceux qui se plaignent le plus du
revenu merci Laurent m'excusant encore
une fois auprès de Fran Fran mon pour
terminer mer madameésid ente merci
monsieur le Président pour pour pour cet
échange une remarque préalable très très
courte je je regrette vraiment votre
position sur elle est respectable et je
la respecte sur les
PSE et et la valorisation de manière
générale des aménités positive de de
l'agriculture deux petites questions
l'implication des établissements publics
fonciers régionaux ou locaux en lien et
en coordination étroite avec les
saffaires pour faciliter le portage du
du du foncier d'installation est-elle
pour vous une piste de travail parce que
je crois que çaen est une intéressante
et deuxème question vous vous avez dit
votre attachement respectable aussi hein
au fonctionnement libéral des marchés
agricole quelle piste de de régulation
pourrez-vous accompagner sur certaines
productions qui emporte avec elle
l'avenir de pan entier du territoire
national c'est le cas en Occitanie avec
la la policulture élevage qui
naturellement se développe sur des
terres
agronomiquement
défavorisé merci merci voilà je vous
demande une petite prouesse monsieur le
Président d'arriver à répondre sur
l'ensemble de ces questions le plus
rapidement possible merci alors juste
que je me reperde dans mes notes la
première question
c'était ah oui autour de écofito et
défi je je quoi dire écofyo et défi a
été au départ conçu pour faire des
référencestir de ferme pilote
donc avec du collectif et cetera je
pense que cette phase là a marché après
on a dit on va utiliser la même méthode
pour accompagner tout le monde non ça ne
marche pas comme ça et un agriculteur
qui est moins à l'aise avec ces sujets
là va pas aller dans un groupe mettre
sur la table son if et cetera quand il
est parfois plus en difficulté et puis
dans un certain nombre de cas il faudra
aller vers de l'accompagnement
individuel ou au moins un bout
d'individuel avant le collectif donc je
crois qu'il faut accepter de dire défi
étaent là pour faire des références et
accompagner des leaders ce à quoi il a
fonctionné et après il faut accompagner
et il faut mettre des moyens sur
l'accompagnement individuel ou un bout
d'individuel et du collectif mais il y a
que par l'accompagnement individuel et
le dernier point c'est
accompagner façon individuelle
l'agriculteur pour qu'il écrive son
projet et pas lui dire ce qu'il doit
faire faire si on veut qu'il soit moteur
voilà il faut porter le projet il faut
porter le projet globalement y compris
avec l'enjeu économique on n'amènera pas
un agriculteur à travailler le sujet de
la réduction des phyos si on travaille
pas en même temps le sujet de son revenu
et de la pénibilité de son travail voilà
d'où une approche un peu global où on
doit aider l'agriculteur à définir son
projet et l'accompagner dans la mise en
œuvre de son projet et ça c'est quand
même aujourd'hui un truc qui n'est plus
financé
euh euh et cofito
après sur sur non globalement sur
écofito je veux dire ce queon souhaite
faire c'est que on souhaite quand même
continuer à travailler avec le
Gouvernement sur ce qui sera mis dans
écophito et moi je pense qu'il faut pas
abandonner le sujet de la réduction des
phyos il faut juste le traiter
différemment et par exemple phyos signal
qui qui était un sujet de débat dans le
monde agricole est pas tout à fait perçu
comme un sujet qui permettra de réduire
les phyos voilà France service
agriculture notre travail majeur je p je
pense avoir déjà répondu en partie on
est plutôt satisfait d'être le guichet
d'accueil on a un vrai sujet qui est un
peu nouveau pour nous c'est
d'accompagner les cédants et pour ça on
a absolument besoin que la MSA nous
communique la liste des cédentss au
moins 5 ans avant le départ pour qu'on
puisse aller rencontrer ses cédents et
préparer avec eux une session en
particulier quand elle se fait plus dans
le cadre familial il y a besoin de plus
de préparation sur les sujets de
capitaux et cetera ce qui me permet de
répondre en même temps à la question de
des EPF et de la saffaire oui on a
besoin des EPF de la safè pour avoir des
plans de portage du foncier mais je le
dis quand même pas nécessairement avec
des bails environnementaux à chaque fois
parfois en laissant quand même le soin à
l'agriculteur de définir la trajectoire
de son exploitation et et en allant
chercher le projet de l'exploitant
euh sur le sujet de la marge des
distributeurs
ou sur le sujet de la régul du du
libéralisme moi je suis pas un champ du
libéralisme enfin me faites pas dire ce
que j'ai pas dit j'ai dit à un moment
que le marché doit accompagner j'avais
compris ça non non moi j'ai dit que le
marché doit accompagner et qu'à un
moment on narrivera pas à développer des
choses si le marché n'arrive pas à le
payer un peu par contre je suis quand
même favorable à une forme de régulation
dans dans ces marchésl euh en tout cas
le sujet du partage de la valeur au sein
de la chaîne de valeur ne se fera pas
s'il y a pas un peu de soutien et de
régulation derrière et notamment c'était
le cas visé par égalim et les contrôles
qui sont nécessaires derrière et cetera
donc moi j'ai pas destas dames là-dessus
pour dire faut qu'il y ait une forme de
régulation c'est qu'une partie de sujet
des productions agricooles on le sait
très bien et Galim couv pas l'ensemble
du CH non mais je je je je redis encore
une fois qu'il a une forme de régulation
me paraît nécessaire et et en tout cas
que la distribution quand elle arrive à
se faire impoger des marge par Coca-Cola
ne rattrape pas ses marges sur le monde
agricole me semble un truc qu'on doit
quand même sur lequel on doit avancer
euh voilà et et et faire en sorte que ce
soi pas les produits haut de gamme qui
soient ou les produits circuit court ou
les produits petit volume qui soit
nécessairement ceux qui font les frais
de de l'histoire
euh
euh sur la Réunion
euh alors il se trouve que j'étais à la
Réunion la semaine dernière y compris
pour constater de mes propres yeux les
dégâts de de venal j'ai rencontré la
filière poulet moi
euh j'entends ce que vous dites sur le
prix mais vous vous ne pourrez pas
demander à l'agriculteur réunionné avec
les contraintes de la réunion de
produire au même prix que du poulet de
dégagement européen donc encore une fois
quelle barrière tarifaire vous mettez ou
quelle règle vous mettez pour réguler un
peu ces distorsions de
concurrence mais l'agriculteur
réunionnais qui doit importer
l'alimentation qui est avec des outil de
plus petit dimensionnement même si j'ai
vu un abattoir de poulet extrêmement
compétitif et bien organisé ne sera pas
en capacité de lter avec du poulet de
dégagement de de l'Union européenne ou
d'ailleurs
euh sur
sur la question
de du sénateur du plomb
sur le le
revenu des
agriculteurs je sais pas bien comment je
dois répondre à la
question en tout cas ce dont je suis sûr
c'est qu'on est en ce moment dans le
basculement des aides à l'installation
au région dans une phase de risque
d'être moins exigeant plutôt que plus
exigeant sur la viabilité de
l'exploitation et la viabilité à tout
niveaux charge de travail he on voit
parfois des jeunes s'installer avec des
plans de travail où ils sont 70 heur de
boulot et ils se sortent un SMIC je suis
désolé mais on les tiendra pas longtemps
comme ça donc il faut qu'on ait des
exigences au moment de l'installation et
au moment de du versement des aides et
et c'est tout le sujet qu'on a essayé de
pousser puisqueen fait le parcours qui
est dans France service agriculture doit
servir à travailler la viabilité du
projet et c'est comment ce parcours là
il est un peu obligatoire pour toucher
les aides et comment un diagnostic de
viabilité du projet est un peu
obligatoire pour toucher les aides et
qu'on acccompagne pas ou qu'on laisse
pas un jeune y aller sur un projet où je
je je on travaille avec initiative
France et Guillaume Pépi sur de des
fonds d'amorçage on va visiter les
exploitations en sc et Marne ensemble la
première exploitation qu'on
voit une une jeune éleveuse de mouton
passionnée par ce qu'elle fait et qui
nous dit aujourd'hui je tire pas de
revenu je vis chez mes parents et
j'espère me tirer un SMIC dans 5 ans
mais en fait on aurait pas dû
accompagner ce projet
là et on aurait dû l'aider à rendre le
projet plus viable il fallait pas lui
dire de rien faire il fallait
l'accompagner dans son projet et donc le
vrai enjeu c'est que dans les aides
régionales demain ce soit le cas juste
peut-être
revenir sur sur si vous m'autorisez tout
à l'heure on m'a parlé séparation
conseil vente moi je je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure qu'il était important qu'on
ait des élus chambres et je suis pas
allé jusqu'au bout du
propos Voilà il se trouve que dans la
prochaine législature les élus chambres
en tout cas il s'agit pas qu'il soi
majoritaire mais des élus chambres qui
sont acteur dans la coopération ou qui
sont comme moi impliqués dans une une
entreprise de travaux agricooles parce
que c'est le moyen que j'ai trouvé de
mutualiser les travaux avec mes voisins
ne pu plus siéger un bureau me paraît
draisonn
et et décaler de la réalité et on a
plutôt besoin de les emmener et
d'emmener tous ces acteurs là sur une
politique commune de réduction donc on
aura besoin de vous pour bouger ça parce
que il faut que ce soit bougé avant les
élections chambre et le
deuxème
voilà et le deuxème point que je voulais
évoquer avec vous et là aussi qu'on a
commencé à travailler avec le sénateur
dupomb c'est au sujet de la loi d'adu on
est en train de préparé en France et et
et je pense que c'est un atout pour
maintenir l'élevage une modernisation de
l'identification de l'élevage le fait de
faire demain du bouclage électronique
qui permettra à l'éleveur de limiter un
certain nombre de paperasses d'avoir
automatiquement les remontées de ses
animaux et
cetera et bien pour faire ça on a besoin
de réformer un peu la loi d'adu et et on
est un peu dans un vide juridique
concernant les établissements de
l'élevage voilà qui qui ont une
accréditation parfois li aux chambres
parfois pas lié aux chambres on a besoin
d'embarquer les filières derrière nous
avec nous et donc il y a un travail qui
est entrepris sur le sujet qui arrivera
chez vous assez vite et on sera à vot
disposition pour répondre aux questions
on n doute absolument pas en tout cas 2
heur d'audition merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président pour l'ensemble de vos des
questions et des réponses extrêmement
précises vous n'avez rien laissé de côté
et on loue véritablement votre votre
engagement et votre détermination et on
vous en remercie très sincèrement on va
tout de suite
accueillir les jeunes agriculteurs et la
Confédération paysane merci beaucoup
merci
allez en s'excusant auprès de